Hello fuckers. What's
cracking? Wait for an answer.
Um, this episode of the podcast
brought to you by new sponsor,
draftkings.com while we
were in Denver last week,
I got schooled on the wonders of
what's the best way to describe this,
this,
this new activity that a lot of you
folks are engaging in called fantasy
football.
It's basically the premise of our friend
Steve run is easy show the league and
the Genre de joure dungeons
and dragons for jocks. Yes,
dungeons and dragons for people
who are really into sports.
And it's a Jamie's a fanatic and it was
sad seeing him scrambled to try to make
his picks. Uh, but I
know people are into it.
And a football season is just around the
corner and you can get your piece of $5
million during kickoff week@draftkings.com
America's favorite one week fantasy
football site. Now, I don't know
much about fantasy football,
but I'm going to have to learn about it
now because Jamie completely perplexed
me this past week.
Greg Fitzsimmons is here and he wrote
a doors logo like we're in high school.
And he wrote about his fucking,
remember we used to do those van
Halen things with the the wings.
Everybody has to do
rolling stones. Lips. Yes.
Everybody said to them in their notebooks.
Anyway,
draft kings for fantasy football folks.
Uh,
you've already been scouting players
and doing research for your season long
team, so you can use that knowledge to
actually win cash the first week of the
season@draftkings.com last year,
one player turned 11 bucks into 4,000
bucks in one week. I heard about that.
Another player won $1 million in one day.
Just playing fantasy football.
How the fuck did a guy when $1 million
in a day playing fantasy football?
Is that real? They must, it must be
real. It's on the ad. That's incredible.
Because he picked Shaquille
O'Neal. It's rookie year. Well,
fantasy football is exciting. Can
you do that? He's already, he's,
you have to pick people that are
not, they're playing right now. Oh,
you don't even know how it goes.
Don't you know she killed near retired.
Shut your mouth. It doesn't. He
play basketball. He's retired.
Draft Kings Dot coms about football.
You fuck,
we can win huge cash starting
the first week of the season.
Don't miss out on week one.
Excitement. Reserve your spot now,
so bounce over to draft
kings.com ended the approach.
Promo Code Rogan that's enter the Promo
Code Rogan and you'll get a free entry
into week one $5 million kickoff
bash@draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings, bigger
millionaires. This is insane.
I can't even believe I'm reading this,
but it is true.
Apparently you could win $1 million.
That's insane. And a Rogan for free.
Entry now@draftkings.com that's draft
kings.com and that is the end of the
fucking sponsors for today.
Why have more when you have Greg
Fitzsimmons and his doors logo? I am.
I am a sponsor.
Experience
night all day,
man. Oh Man. Don't buddy smoke
a little right at doors. Logo.
Settle in. Greg wrote up for
folks who are just tuning in now,
Greg wrote a doors logo on his notebook
like as if we were in high school when
we all used to do that in high school.
Everybody. I used to do the kiss logos,
but kiss, fan kiss,
the ss were like triangles on
top, right know. Yeah. It's like,
well the DAS is go like a
z sort of. Yeah. Like, Hey,
um, did do bands do that anymore?
Do they still have logos? Yeah,
but did they have logos? The kids like
draw on their notebooks or anything.
And I n give a nine
inch nails is not today.
And I need snails from the nineties bands
of today. Like they were really stung.
Could do led Zepplin member has like a
million little scribbles and kids got
props. So we're really
good at that. Right?
Like a kid could do a solid doors
logo from scratch. Like wow. Well My,
uh,
one of my best friends,
we used to sit in the back row baked
in eighth grade and he would draw on a
desks, you know, shit like
the doors, logos and all that.
And I was the class clown.
And now like all these years later, he's
one of the top record, uh, designers.
In the contrary, he works for Jimmy
Hendricks is a state for awhile.
Doing all those,
like that rereleases that they did and
he did all those album covers that my
uncle used to do that my uncle used
to work for Howard marks advertising,
which was the company that used to
produce kiss album covers and that was a
little kid.
I'm at ace freely.
He's really came to the office and he
had no makeup on, which was just insane.
It was like I was seeing the Easter
bunny without his fucking clothes on.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I couldn't even believe he was really
there and the fact that he didn't have
makeup on,
it was like,
it was almost like a life changing event
for like a 10 year old or whatever the
fuck I was. Cause it was just, I can't,
couldn't believe he, this was eight,
really didn't have his makeup on housing.
How's he just walking around?
And then I realized what
a brilliant move that was.
They were famous but nobody knew
what they looked like. Genius.
Oh it's the greatest movie of
all times. Yeah. Like look,
the insane clown posse has the same thing.
The insane clown posse.
It could be at the fucking seven 11,
right next to you buying cigarettes.
You would have no idea.
You don't know what they look like.
Is that what they look? No, that's
ace freely. That's ace freely today.
Or a voice over guys like they get
mad groaning and the guys that do the
Simpsons voices, they're making more
than anybody and they're got all,
they can sit in it in a restaurant without
getting annoyed. Yeah, that's so true.
Well, Matt stone and Trey Parker became
famous. Like they, they became famous,
they did their own movie and then they've
done so many interviews and they've
done like, they took acid and went to
the Oscars. Remember that? Dresses,
no shit.
There were women's dresses were on acid.
That's amazing. They're the greatest.
They're so important for the culture.
Guys like that are so important. Guys
that can make those kinds of shows there.
So
did you see, uh, the book of
Mormon? Yes. Dude loved it.
That opening song,
I started laughing so fucking hard.
And then I looked around the theater and
people come in and they know it's Matt
stone and Trey Parker. So they're like,
all right, this is going to be shocking.
Right. But then when they start singing,
fuck God and the mouth, ass and cons,
and I'm laughing and I see the people
are pulling back half the half,
the audience can't handle it.
That makes me laugh twice as hard and I,
and if they're like far into the whole
next scene and I'm still doubled over.
Oh God,
that was fucking brilliant.
Yeah. While you're in the dress, it's
just such a magical evening and everyone,
it's just everyone looked so spectacular.
You know,
we're just wanting to be a
part of [inaudible] magic.
[inaudible]
magic. Oh, that's great
dude.
When they did that fucking South Park
movie and Satan and Saddam Hussein were in
bed together and you see Satan stick and
they're allowed to shows deck because
it's fake. It's cause it's rubber, you
know, so they have like this rubber Dick,
but it's was the movie.
It's so ridiculous.
It was so ridiculous. You're like,
how are they getting away with this?
They push so hard to like,
one of the reasons why they get away
with putting all their shit in the movies
is they put a bunch of stuff in the movies
that are so fucked up that they have
some bargaining tools.
Like they'll cut out some of this other
stuff that they weren't planning on
putting in there anyway.
Yeah, like the uh,
have you ever seen the full sex scene
between the two puppets and team America?
Now they shit on each other. They
piss on each other. I mean it's crazy.
He drops a log on her chest.
It's so take that out.
Yeah. So the scene is insane
already. It's all right.
I remember the scenes and same was way
over the top in real life or the original
version. But they probably, they do,
I know they do that shit on purpose.
Like we used to do that.
Like Paul seems to just do
that on news radio on purpose.
Like they would say penis. Like there
was a, an episode where bill was a bill.
Mcneil was Phil Hartman's character,
how to say penis on the air.
And he said penis like a hundred
times, you know, and they, we,
they put in like all these extra penises
so they could trim it down. Right.
And that episode like didn't
air until the third season.
They pulled that episode. Yeah. Like
it's too controversial. All right.
And then they aired it like in the third,
third or fourth season.
Did it seem weird?
Like did you even want to like look
different like out of nowhere one week
somebody had like purple hair instead
or shorter hair or you know what I mean?
Do you mean cause it
was a different season?
No, no, no. Well, yeah, I would
definitely look different.
Like, you know, three years,
people's faces change a little, just
a slight amount. You know, it was,
I went to the,
um,
the Phil Hartman had a star of fame
put on the Hollywood walk of fame.
He had a star and I went there and there
were some people that I hadn't seen in
16, 17 years. Like a lot of the writers
and a lot of people that worked on staff.
It was weird.
It's like, wow, we're all getting
fucking old. This is strange. Yeah,
laughing about it.
But it is strange to see the weathering.
Like my friend Lou, who I picture
is this like boy faced young kids,
hilarious writer, Lou Morton.
He had gray hair. It's like wow,
I'm finally getting around now.
We just got together,
me and a few college friends and I hadn't
seen them in years and I looked around
and you start to think,
wow,
I must not look as good as I think because
they look fucking terrible. I never,
my peers, you know,
one guy is bad as shit.
So if you get fat enough,
there is a key to aging where if you
can put enough fat into your face,
it's like botox and you don't wrinkle
and you kind of have that youthful glow
cause you're just filled with oil.
We know William Schachner
allegedly does that on purpose.
I can see in Schachner says
I put on five pounds a year
and five pounds a year,
keeps his face around.
And I give it I just for men and
I keep it fat. Is that a move?
Yeah. No, you're just coming up
with an excuse for TPN fat, Bro.
That's not true.
Dr Pepper 10 and just say that man,
because William Shatner actually
plans it so you can't claim it.
That is an amazing [inaudible] used
to do when I wanted to get out of
relationships, it's pretty
much the same thing. I just,
you just fatten up fat them out.
Did you ever hit,
remember that Kinison bit about
getting out of relationships now. Oh,
you're the best bet. Who's
like, you know not. He's like,
I don't ever break up with him. He goes,
I get them to break up with me. That fee,
that way they feel bad
that they left me when I,
when I needed them most it's flawless.
Like he did this thing where he says,
I just stay up for weeks and do coke and,
and then when they go, Sam, I just,
you're just not the guy that you
were when I met you and I'm sorry,
but I have to go
and Sheila, that's flawless. Chill.
I best part about it.
She feels bad because she left
you one year later at my house
and you got to go out and
do coke for three weeks.
Have you ever heard Marin till
the Kinison stories? Oh yeah.
When he got pissed off
he pissed on his bed.
Well just how crazy they were with coke.
Yeah.
Man was on our podcast and he said that
he heard voices in his head for almost a
year. Who Kinison did no
Marin. Oh, from trauma.
So much coke. Yeah, they did so
much coke. He was hearing voices.
Wow Dude. For like a year. Yeah.
He said that Kennison would just red
line it all day and he was just gone for
[inaudible]. It was like, like
what? What stops did he make in,
cause he was like on the sunset strip
going to like record store diner bar,
strip club. Like in one day he would make
more stops than you would in a month.
Yeah. Just ripped out of his mind.
Sleeping three hours a night sometimes.
Didn't sleep for days apparently.
Yeah, he was an animal. He was,
the funniest thing about him was that
he was a reverend for people who are,
if you,
if you never heard Kinison gold
go download louder than hell.
It was so offensive that Warner
Bros never released it as a CD.
I was like one of the
greatest comedy albums ever,
but it's only on cassette
because Warner brothers,
so much homophobic stuff on there.
So much stuff that was so
offensive to gay people, you know.
And uh, so that was, that was never
released. It was never released as a CD.
I used to have it as a cassette,
but people have put it up now
you can get it to like in a fine.
Did it through Torrance is now on
iTunes or anything like that? Um,
I don't think it's on Itunes, man.
It might be to see if it is no,
no louder than hell. Loud as hell. Louder
than how I think it's louder than how,
uh,
it's his first a CD and then some of the
material is similar to what was on his
first atrial special. Like there's some
crossover with some of the material,
but it's his best stuff. Those two, the
his HBO special and Louder Than Hell.
Those are the GPS specialists
from Montreal, right? No,
it was from the Roxy right up
the street from the comedy store.
He did it at that theater on sunset.
It's just perfect because it's on there.
Is it? It's on there. I'll
be, yeah, that's it man.
That right there. My opinion,
best comedy CD ever.
That's my number one.
Somebody had to say to me what was the
most influential comedy CD? That's it.
I think he was the best ever for a year
having for one year plus two years,
whatever it was when he was just a
maniac. Right. But you just can't,
you can't keep that going because it's
so awful because he was on the crest of
the wave. The wave, a wave
has depth. There's like,
there's a lot of failure and a lot of
frustration underneath the ocean and it
builds and till it swells and in that
fucking wave pops out and that's where he
was on the crest of that
wave and he wrote it.
And he got to shore
and just fucking crash.
He was a superstar.
All the sudden it's at an Eto for
that was pretty God damn good.
Similar to hunter s Thompson's metaphor
about what happened in the 70s.
You ever heard that thing?
It's done to like, it's great.
It was in, um, the movie,
uh, the um, the Johnny Depp
movie. Oh yeah. Um, uh,
fear and loathing in Las Vegas.
Where played him.
Johnny Depp did an awesome job of a pull
down up, see if we could find it. Um,
the, uh, Wav speech from fear
and loathing and Michael Steal.
Did I just steal that? No, no.
You've probably never heard it. Now,
did you ever read fear and loathing now?
Oh,
so Johnny Depp was at the comedy store
the other day watching duct Stan hope
that's their buddies. That's
another thing though, that,
that he's another one.
Hunter s Thompson was another one
of my all time favorites. Yeah.
He's another one that just burnt it out,
man.
This used to read them in Rolling Stone
magazine or you'd read or read his books.
The first one I read
was a fear and loathing.
It's not on
this strange memories on this
nervous night in Las Vegas.
Has it been five years,
six,
it seems like a lifetime.
The kind of peak never comes again.
See servers just go in the
middle sixties this is it, right?
There was a very special time
and place to be a part of,
but no explanation,
no mixer words or music or memories can
touch that sense of knowing that you
were there and alive and not
corner of time in the world,
whatever it meant.
I always madness in any direction.
At any hour you could
strike sparks anywhere.
There was a fantastic universal sense.
Whatever we were doing was
right that we were winning
and that I think was the handle.
That sense of inevitable victory
over the forces of old and evil,
not in any mean or military sense.
We didn't need that.
Our energy would simply prevail.
We had all the momentum.
We were riding the crest of
a high and beautiful way.
So now,
less than five years later,
you can go up on a steep hill
in Las Vegas and look West.
And with the right kind of eyes,
you can almost see the high water mark.
That place where the wave
finally broke and rolled back.
Johnny Depp's a bad motherfucker.
He has a bad mother fucker.
He's a bad motherfucker. Got To get back
this deck off. Yeah, but that was he,
that guy,
hunters Thompson was real similar to me
to Kennison cause he just burnt it out.
It was all coke was just
coke and booze and just wow.
And then he wrote a couple of great books
and then there was just nothing left.
And then towards the end,
I mean he was,
if you've ever seen a hunters
Thompson on Letterman, it's sad. Yeah,
because you can't,
you literally can't understand him.
We can't understand the words that are
coming out of his mouth. Like he's,
you think he just fried his brain or
it could ride it, cooked it, barbecue,
sauteed it, minced it up, ran it through
a fucking grind or fried it again.
And it wasn't just coke, he
was every hill, everything,
everything. A lot of acid,
everything he gives hands on who's a
mania. Yeah. There's a video or a, um,
an article rather where a reporter
followed him around and monitored his drug
usage for the day. It's insane.
Yeah. It's insane. I mean it's, it's,
I don't know if this is a typical day,
but this was this one day and I bet it
was a typical day cause he always talked
about it.
I guess your system just gets used to it.
You can see him doing this hand.
Things like where he's going.
Like Thompson used to do that.
When you write somebody,
a friend of ours that does all the
time and I would that, well, you know,
it's sort of like, uh, uh, it's visceral.
He may have some kind of
learning disorder. Drinking.
Yeah. King. He's thinking,
he's like, right. That's all it is. All
right. Here's, here's his daily routine.
3:00 PM rise thrill.
Five Chivas regal with morning papers.
Smokes done hills.
Three 45 cocaine,
three 50 another glass of Chivas,
another Dunhill 4:05 PM by the way,
First Cup of coffee and a Dunhill for 15
cocaine for 16 orange juice and another
Dunhill for 30 cocaine for 54 cocaine,
five oh five cocaine,
five 11 coffee done hills five 30 get
more ice in the Chivas cocaine at five 45
six o'clock smoking grass. Take
the edge off the day. 7:00 PM day,
three hours into it.
Three hours in lit.
Seven oh five woody
creek tavern for lunch.
Heineken to Margarita's Cole Slaw,
a Taco Salad,
double order of Fried Onion rings,
carrot cake, ice cream of being fritter,
done hills, another Heineken cocaine.
And for the rest of the ride home,
a snow cone,
a glass of shredded ice,
which is poured over four jiggers of
Chivas. Okay, so the snow cone is Chivas.
Okay, 9:00 PM start
snorting cocaine. Seriously,
10:00 PM dropped acid,
11:00 PM chartreuse. I don't know
what that is. Cocaine and grass.
1130 cocaine,
etc. Etc.
12 midnight hunters Thompson
is ready to write. Wow.
That's when he sits down to write
1205 to 6:00 AM he writes chartreuse,
cocaine, grass, Shivaas coffee, Heineken,
closed cigarettes, grapefruit done hills,
orange juice, gin, continuous
pornographic movies.
6:00 AM in the hot tub with champagne,
dove bars,
fettuccine Alfredo,
8:00 AM Halcion,
which is sleeping pill,
not eight 20 sleep,
so he would take a sleeping pill at
eight 20 in the morning after a riding it
hard wood I love is that most people,
it's about if I get this work done,
then I can have a drink. Nope.
Inhibits the opposite. Yeah. He got x,
Y. Yeah. He got wild to the core
where there was nothing left,
but just savage chemicals flowing through
the brilliant core of his mind and
then he just sat in front of that
typewriter and let it rip for six hours.
Focused it to that. Yeah. Wow.
I love it. Ah, that's what you
can't, you can't do that for long.
If it doesn't last, and in
the end it's ugly. Pull up.
Pull up a hunter Thompson
on David Letterman.
It's kind of like life is about finding
that line where you are pushing yourself
and you are finding your edge but
you're not burning yourself out.
This is way more than an edge. I
mean this is, it's a suicidal thing.
And with hunter also had it in his head
that when the time would come he would
take his own life. Yeah.
He just, he was like,
just this getting old shit is nice to
pressure off. Yeah. He was convinced.
I mean he had told everyone around
him that uh, when it gets too much,
I'm just going to end this.
Like I'm not gonna I'm not going to
slowly drift away when I know there's no
hope in sight. Yeah. And for him,
like they would do operations on them.
Like did a hip operation, like you
gotta stop drinking. He's like,
get the fuck Outta here. Boom. Hits it
that night. Like right away. What is this?
Oh here we go.
I don't know if this is the right
one cause he's on and been on a lot.
This is from 2012.
Oh that's perfect.
2012 is perfect because that's the end.
I don't even think he was alive in
2012 now when did he kill himself?
We got done with this a lot
longer than two years ago.
I made this, this myth uploaded
into 2000 uploaded. Uploaded,
uploaded. It's pretty recent though.
No, no, no, no. I mean not that reason.
Yeah, fairly right. It's not, it's not
old Letterman with a full head of hair.
Right?
Yeah.
By all means.
Make yourself at home.
Yeah.
He died in 2005.
Move this away from, you know, it's
been a long time since I've seen you.
Help me refresh my memory. Doctor, your
doctor is what, what if, what area,
what discipline are you a doctor in
of [inaudible] that last time it was
divinity. Oh yeah. Put
the Ruby [inaudible]
and uh,
journalism. Where did you go to, to study?
Yeah. Where did you get your divinity? Uh,
where? Where, where the [inaudible] story.
Really? Yeah. Where did you go to Yale?
Where you as a seminary and ideas? I go
to the yield. It would've been spooled.
Where did you go, hunter? How going to
discuss the he you'd rather move on? Yeah.
Okay. You went to state? I went
to ball state. Not all states.
Sorry. The ball state. Uh,
I been all right. Yeah.
You're 60 years old now. Is that, is
that right? Yeah. That seems weird.
I bet you were doing,
you know,
ah,
really, uh, it had been so
long. Yeah. Does this mean
anything to you? Turn in 60?
Is it?
Oh No. That'll let that Nigga, yeah.
The guys will say have gone
to some dark sense of humor.
Do you have any real in this world?
This is actually way better
than the one I was thinking of.
The one I was thinking of now that
I remembered is actually in Conan.
He was on Conan. Conan went shooting
with them. Right. They went out to his,
uh,
woody creek.
He has this place in woody creek with a
lot of land and they would just set up
things and just fucking blown away
with guns and he had Conan out there.
I'm blown out guns with them and I swear
he could barely understand them. Yeah.
It was just heck good line though.
I thought you were dead till. Yeah.
Shark let him, he didn't expect
that up or at evercat. Yeah, he's,
he was a funny dude. You say, well that's
not going to happen. I said, all right,
let's do it. We brought a camera
crew. Here's what happened.
I think they're ready over on
the firing range. Should we
head over that way?
Yeah.
And the idea is you're going to instruct
me and how to blow things to hell.
Well, no, we're going to
do art. Art, what kind of
glue boards.
That's good.
Loose with the club.
Yeah.
Loosen us up the drinking
booze and shooting things.
So that was pretty good. Those his
character on doing right? Yeah.
They used to make fun of them on
Doonesbury. Well that's a good example.
I guess it's better as it gets
on and he gets more drunk.
I guess that's probably why.
Couldn't understand them.
But if you go from that
to what he sounded like,
how articulate he was when he was younger,
how clear it was to understand,
you know, like from the, uh,
the documentary Gonzo life and
times of hunter s Thompson.
There's some interviews with him when
he was in black and white and you know,
you got to see what he
was like as a young man.
Think there's some serious deterioration.
By the time he got to 60. Yeah.
Any perspective.
Sylvester Stallone is 67 or 68.
And he shredded, you know, talks great.
Still do an action movies, you know,
that just shows you the impact
that hunter put on his body. Yeah.
60 whatever it was there.
well and that he lived. So he
actually has a strong, you know, he,
he could handle that shit.
Most people would've died of liver
disease or killed themselves before.
Well, sixties don't tend to hold them
out. I mean, he would, he was 62,
62 when he died that
even think about this,
40 something years of pounding
substances in your body now.
Probably not exercising
ever. No, no eating,
eating fucking dove bars and a hot tub.
Fuck man.
Fettuccine Alfredo at eight o'clock
in the morning. He was in the animal.
Would you do that if you knew you could
come back and you wouldn't be addicted
and you wouldn't be dead, would you
take that lifestyle on for one month?
No, I wouldn't want them to
feel like that. Yeah. I see.
I'm not a speed guy at all.
I don't like, I like coffee.
It's good for conversation. Yeah. But
I have no desire to try the speeds.
No, I just mean more in terms of
completely being obliterated. Yeah, just
I, I couldn't do it. Yeah. I
couldn't do it because I would know.
I know too much about what it's doing to
my body. Like I could do it for a night,
for a night. I could go on a bender.
Do you do that? I have, yeah. Yeah.
I've definitely had some nights where
I got just destroyed. But again,
there's no code.
There's no coke involved and you know,
it was mostly Jack Daniels
or something that just
a few too many shots getting crazy,
smoking too much weed.
But the big difference between that and
what he was doing was he was doing it
all day. I mean, if I
would do it, it'd be like,
can you start at 10 by one
o'clock in the morning,
you're basically done and then you'll
just try to find somewhere to eat and
sober up. But this guy was
gunning it all day like that,
writing books and he went three hours
before he put solid food in his body.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And just
drinking and doing coke,
smoking done hills.
I mean I have too much.
I have too much carbs in the afternoon.
I need to nap at four o'clock I think
partly like I quit drinking a long time
ago. Part of it was like, I just didn't
want to deal with the hangover energy.
Awful. It's one of the worst
feelings. Still waste a time.
You just feel like such a fucking idiot.
Like I just sacrificed several days.
It's almost like,
like say if you had a job that really
sucked and you worked for like a week,
saved up all your money and then you went
to the casino and you blew it in five
seconds, like you fucking
idiot all the time you wasted.
It seems almost similar when you're
hung over because it's like, Whoa,
what did I have fun for an hour.
And then the last two hours were a fog
and then I threw up and then I went to
sleep and then I woke up and I
feel like death for two days.
What that can be worth it.
Well,
I can remember being young enough where
I'd hook up with a one night stand,
shit faced, get it done. Never had a
problem getting it done. Always closed.
So for you, go for you. And
then waking up in the morning,
still drunk and then
going for the morning sex.
I feel good about it because then after
that there was no hangover after the
morning sex. It's just like a light
buzz, but that's it. You know 21 yeah,
2021 you were a different thing.
You're a battery for a full battery,
just church plus your free.
You can't believe no one's
telling you what to do.
You can't believe for the
first time in your life.
No one is telling you when
you have to go to bed,
when you have to be home like you're a
man, you're a free man for the first time.
Those years are a buck wild. Those years
from whenever you get out of the house,
whenever you're paying your own bills,
whenever you have a g like you,
like I guess I'm an adult now, I
have a job and an apartment. Whoa.
Yeah,
and you're deciding when you go to bed.
He had a way you feel like an adult and
in a way you feel like a little child
because that little child gets to play
and explore the night like you know,
all of a sudden at four 30 in the morning,
you're not like now if I'm up at
four 30 in the morning, I'm like,
how the fuck do I get to bed as soon as
possible. Then you're like, what else?
What else can we stumble on?
Is there a door I can knock on?
Is there possibly a booty call I can
make right now? Yeah. Who's got coke?
How do you keep this thing rolling?
And then just like you,
your mortgaged your house and
then on top of the mortgage,
like when the coke comes into the picture,
it's like now you just taking out
loans from, from shylocks now.
Now you're going to fucking to the worst
loan sharks and be like, listen, listen,
listen. One Week I'll pay you
back on paying it all back.
That's how you feel when you do the coke.
The coke is the one that I docked
docked at my whole life. I love it.
Love it too much.
Just start talking so much.
You do 20 podcasts at the
same time. That's what my
friend Jimmy Law was told me.
Like when we were in high school,
they were,
they were all doing it at this party
and uh, Jimmy goes, don't do it.
You'd like it too much. And I go, okay,
that's all I need to hear. Anytime.
A guy who likes to do coke
tells you not to do coke.
And he didn't like to do coke, but uh,
he had a cousin that liked to do coke.
It's just I saw too many kids
but any kids that were just,
they would just be engrossed in it. It's
all they wanted. And I saw kids, you know,
we did all the drugs but coke
was too expensive. So we did it.
But it was kind of a luxury item.
We were more like a lot of my friends
were doing angel dust cause that was cheap
and a lot of masculine. Do you ever take
masculine? Never took it. It's kind of a,
it's I think it's a form of acid, right?
No masculine is a foreign pod. Oh it is?
Yeah. Yeah. It's very like colorful. You
see a lot of colors and you laugh a lot.
Yeah. Um, that's a, that's
shit I never got ahold of.
I never got to hold those all,
like when that was going around like
mask that was all going around like post
high school, like just after high school
when I was in my super healthy phase.
Yeah. All throughout, like from
high school to like, you know,
21, 22. There was very little drinking,
very little partying, very, very little.
The occasional joint would come
out if I had a couple of beers,
but it was so rare and that
was felt guilty after I did it.
That was those the healthy days I was
selling masculine for a little while.
This guy,
this Guy Andre,
the blackest blacker than your cough
and tough and he was like in and out of
Juvie homes.
And so he got me to sell it to my friends.
So I would have a bad cause like a lot
of my friends were into the grateful dead
and we go to a dead shell and I would
just sell like a hundred hits a masculine.
And so, uh, so then one day,
I guess I didn't even owe him money.
Like he,
he would give me a bag and then I pay him
after I sold it and time wasn't really
up yet.
But I came home one afternoon and I opened
the front door to my house and I walk
in and we lived in a pretty nice house
and my mom is sitting with Andre and the
living room having tea and
she never met him. She just,
he just showed up looking
for me and I was like,
oh what the fuck does
uncomfortable that ended my,
my drug dealing days ended
her right there. Yeah.
You don't want Andrea
embedded in your life.
Imagine if you count a hunter was
banging your mom cause he would do that.
I know Andre and she's on mask. I
know Andre. Andre would do it. Yeah.
He lit up her drink. He had tea
with her, dropped a tablet or tea.
Right now the doors are playing two
riders on the storm and you open the door
and he just fucking hammering your
arm from behind. Father. Yes son,
I want to kill you.
And to this out in a bone.
Tanto Tanto
Oh, and you're like, why?
And I walk in and he turns his head
and sees me and he gives me a look that
makes me have to fucking leave the room.
Eat mid stroke.
Doesn't even stop banging my mom. Wow.
Yeah. Yeah. You don't want to see this.
I don't want to see that shit. And
I'm on mask. Jedi mind trick too.
These are not the droids
you're looking for
Andre. Work in every angle. Think of
someone like that. Bang in your mom.
Oh, that's dark. Yeah, that would be
brutal. That's the door seeing his ass.
You know that prison ass.
You don't know what it's been through.
It's probably got stride and
muscle tissue all throughout a two.
It looks terrifying,
right?
Do you think about the moment force he
could generate without ass? Oh my God.
Yeah. Strong thighs because he's
walking around selling drugs.
He's out on the street.
It's not a constant motion while cardio
and now he's got the back of though size,
ripping and driving.
You know that drive you get from the
inside of your thighs when you're real
fucking, he's doing that
to her. Oh Lord. Oh,
is this Erin? No, no, no,
no. We'll edit that part out.
Do you know when riders on the storm,
he does one track singing and this
another track he's whispering. Really?
It's really hot and yeah,
play it. It's like, uh,
at the same time and pulled off of
Youtube. If we play it won't win. Oh,
and you never know why that's
over. Let's just do it. Okay, well,
let's see.
I never knew why it was so haunting
and then you hear that and it's like,
fuck this video doesn't post cool shit.
Back in the 60s when they were
coming back, we multitrack recording.
They were doing all kinds
of cool shit and you know,
the Beatles backtracking stuff. Oh, that
was Phil Spector. That is that right?
His wall of sound. Right. If you
don't know the Phil Spector story,
Phil Spector was known for pulling
guns on people. That was his thing.
He would always pull guns on people.
And uh, he got back to his house.
He picked up some woman,
I think at the House of Blues.
I think she was like a waitress or
something. Got Her back to his house,
put a gun in her mouth and pull the
trigger and blew her fucking brains out
and went through this big
trial because of, yeah.
And in the trial he would
wear like different wigs
every day he was bald and so
you wear these crazy like 1960s wigs,
like the most ridiculous wigs ever. Like
during his trial. Yeah, I remember that.
Pull up. Pull up some old photos of
Phil Spector's wig. Here's the doors.
Whisper track is just the track
with the whisper in the percussion.
Yeah,
he was the sexy.
Did fuck
okay.
Wow.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that's haunting.
This is Phil Spector.
When he was in in court for
murder and he's wearing that wig.
That's not a Photoshop either.
That was a wig and were different ones.
Like some days they would be different
if you had a couple of different wigs.
You do find the other ones.
I get so confused cause that trial
happened I think around the same time as a
wow Ellen degeneres on trial.
It's Martina Navratilova
mixed with Ellen degenerate.
Don't ask me how the fuck I
pulled Martina Navit piece.
BCIT troll in the middle of
it somehow never troll over.
Wasn't she like one of the first
lesbians like the first thing? Yeah,
she came out during the aids thing and
uh, that was like the 80s, right? Yeah,
I guess not. You know,
84 85 she had balls.
Tough chick. No tennis balls. Yeah.
She's, she's a bad ass that she did.
This is what he really is.
Oh, that's gruesome. Yeah.
It looks like the guy that killed
Patrick wets his face and ghost Patrick.
Uh, no. You know, you know
that was, that was, uh,
the comic who died of AIDS. Black
Guy in New York. Charlie Burnett.
No other black guy in New
York who died of AIDS.
He Not Black Hispanic.
Oh.
Who the fuck was that?
Died of AIDS.
I remember because I started dating his
girlfriend about six months later. Oh,
that dude. Yeah. No, he died
too. Yeah. How did he die?
I don't know. Something with
this face. Probably what?
Phil Spector didn't die that fucker.
He's in jail. They nailed him.
They nailed him down.
I guess I need bank checks.
He would like to put guns
in their mouth and shit.
I could see that and he
wound up shooting her. Yeah,
it might've been that or it might've
been just the murder. I don't know.
Well if you think about if you had no
value on human life and everyone's trying
to go for the big, the biggest orgasm
you can get, whether it's doing
coke, grabbing your own
balls, cock ring with,
think about blowing someone's head
off as you came. That would be huge.
That would probably be,
if you are like a total psychopath,
that would probably be the the end all
be like calming and taking at the same
time,
putting human life into her as you take
it out of her and then imagining that
your loads actually got her pregnant and
that that kid would be born to a body
that just died.
Would it be conceived to a body that
just doing the loads get to the egg,
the loads crack open the egg
and they're like, sorry boys.
The factory has been shut
down. There's a, she's dead,
but we just got here. He just came
inside her. The eggs are here,
everything's do it, let's do it.
Her spirit goes into his dick hole.
It's like the opposite of an
abortion. She dies, baby lifts.
The baby gets conceived
like the first days of life.
That is the right. That's the number
one debate when it comes to abortion.
It's not whether or not women should
have to keep the baby and get pregnant.
The real debate is when
is it actually a person?
Cause I don't think it's a
person with two cells. You know,
I think if this is you see two cells
there and those two cells could grow to
become a person.
I feel like if be snuffed those two cells
right now there and then you're good.
I don't feel like you killed somebody,
but if it gets to be like six months and
it's inside the woman's body and could
live outside of her womb,
is that a baby? When, what?
At what year or at what month rather
Jonathan Katz, he used to say,
I think life begins after
the Second Cup of coffee.
I think it's, I think it's right out of
the gate. Right out of the box. Yeah.
Inception right into the box.
Like as soon as that thing turn,
as soon as that thing combines the
ag and that's the life. That's it.
I'm not saying you shouldn't be able to
kill it. I'm just saying it is a lie.
Don't kid yourself like don't
say don't fucking soft sell it.
If you're going to get an abortion,
you got an abortion.
If you took the morning after pill,
you have boarded a life,
you have the right to do
it and I support that.
But don't pretend it wasn't a
high stakes what you just did.
That's so important to say and so taboo.
Like what you're doing right now is
so like you that can be demonized.
You can be thought of as insensitive.
People can get angry and yell at you.
They've,
people have concocted certain politically
acceptable phrases for certain things
and abortion, you know, for abortion,
the number one issue is always
a woman's right to choose,
but a women's right to choose.
Exactly. What are you doing?
Like what are you doing?
I'm down for you having the right to
do whatever you want with your body.
I don't think that anybody,
especially anybody that can't have
a life in their body like a man,
we can't even understand what that is.
It's too, it's too far outside
the, it's impossible for us. It's,
it's only like fiction.
It's only like when we,
when we try to pretend to understand,
to put ourselves in the mind
of a woman that's pregnant,
we're just making things up.
We have no point of reference whatsoever.
It's a whole dementia. It's a different
dimension. So I don't think it's our,
I don't think it's any of our business,
but as far as that,
as far as like whether or not a woman
should be able to end this life form
inside of her body,
but why do we have this desire to
pretend that it's something other than a
person? Like I got in this
argument with this dude on Twitter.
This comics seems to be a funny guy,
but he kept calling me right wing and
saying that I was saying right wing
talking points and I said,
listen,
I'm 100% in support of a
woman's right to choose your,
you're hearing me wrong here.
But what I'm saying is it was
because Dawkins had compared a,
um, uh, a fetus inside
a body that you know,
that it was like, I think he had
compared it to like a baby pig.
I forget what the, a, the, I forget that
no more of a human than a baby pig is,
you know, I guess he's talking in
scientific terms how like a very,
very young fetus,
like whatever age it is,
when you decided to feed us
and he was saying that, I
was like, that's ridiculous.
That's such a ridiculous point.
And it fucks up the whole argument because
obviously that baby pig can't become
a person, but that fetus is going to be
a person. Everybody fucking knows it.
So stop playing this game.
This is a stupid game. Yeah.
And then this comic starts going at me
for like this UK guy, Frankie Boyle.
It seems like a nice guy.
Seems like a funny guy, you
know? But he was saying that,
I was saying all these right wing
talking points and I'm a, and I'm like,
I'm not right wing by any stretch
of the imagination, but what is it?
That's not a seed man.
It's not a seed. Okay.
Seed has to be planted to become life.
That fucker's planted. That's a sapling.
It's a person.
It's going to be a person.
If you keep eating food and
you don't take too much heroin,
that's going to be a fucking person.
And, and we all think about what our
lives I, the miracle of, you know,
not knowing how the universe works.
And you know,
there's theories in those paradigms and
their scientific data and we've got,
we're getting a broad sense of what,
what the,
what the actual material end of it is.
But the magic of the sperm and egg
becoming something like that's it.
No, that is when life begins.
And you know, we don't know why.
We don't know if there's a god making
it happen or if it really is like a
million monkey's typing Shakespeare.
But it happened and it's like, well I'm,
I'm offended whenever anyone tries to
lump any discussion of any subject into
one of those categories where you can't
question it or one of those categories
where it's not open to discussion
that there is a certain acceptable uh,
opinion on it. Yeah. You're supposed
to have as an intelligent person,
as a progressive,
you're supposed to have one opinion
and if you questioned that at all,
deviate outside of that one opinion
at all. You are a piece of shit.
You're a bad person, you know, you, you,
you're outside of what we're
all trying push. We have an
agenda to push.
If you talk outside of that agenda.
I mean for a comic to think like that to
me is particularly offensive cause like
you're not, we're not being
honest about what it actually is
and also it's,
it's just putting issues into black
and white terms instead of knowing.
It's like, you know, I can't,
I can not support the war and
I can still support the troops.
Can I have that fucking distinction or
is it who wants one or the other nuance
thought. Right. It's like people now
saying, I support the state of Israel.
I don't support the government of
Israel right now and what they're doing.
You can do both. You don't
have to be fucking, you know,
a Zionist or an anti Zionist and it's
the same thing with this. It's like,
you know,
abortion being something that is in the
hands of women exclusively is a fucking
weird situation because
ultimately the man is involved.
So can we at least have
an opinion about it?
Well, you know, even if you
have an opinion about it,
I mean I'm not calling for an opinion
that I should have any opinion as to
whether or not a woman should do it.
I removed myself from that.
I should have no opinion. This is what
I think. This is my, my belief. I can't,
I don't think I can stop you from doing
something to your body at a certain
point in time. When is it a moral though?
Is it a moral when it's nine months old,
it wasn't it a moral,
if you have an abortion in the day before
your kid was going to be born. That's,
that's a real question.
And to pretend that's not a real
question I think is preposterous.
I mean it's preposterous. It
doesn't, doesn't make any sense.
Like how can you not discuss this?
You don't want this discuss because
this is not in the framework of what you
think is like progressive liberal
thought that that'd becomes a problem.
No, I've been doing this bit where I
asked the women in the audience said,
do you support a woman's right to choose?
And then they almost all clap.
And then I say,
and how many of you have had abortions
and nobody ever fucking claps.
And I was like, you know, that's
a right, that's under attack.
And if you are ashamed
to say that you do it,
you're going to lose that fucking right.
Like I'm like,
I'm ashamed that I masturbate, but you
outlawed. I'm walking down main street,
my dick out like hell no. So, I mean,
I think that that's the thing about that,
about abortion as if
you shrouded in shame,
which the Republicans do and which
women are owning and absorbing,
they shouldn't internalize it. They
should say, no, I have, I've had abortion.
I don't think it's any of our business.
I don't think,
I think the thing about asking someone
if they've had an abortion is like,
you know, it's, you're,
you're asking a very intimate question
to someone where it's probably an opinion
or a decision that they had to make where
maybe it wasn't a happy time. You know,
maybe it's a dark moment.
So you're asking them to tell you
some person that they've never met,
that they have this dark memory,
that they have this thing in
their life they're not happy with.
Like just because everybody has an
opinion or just because you know,
someone has an abortion rather,
it doesn't mean that the way they look
at that abortion is a happy thing or
relief or something that, you know, they
would do. Again, it might be a, but it's
been framed as a political
issue and so they will that,
that personal thing that they
don't want to talk about.
If they never talk about it,
they're not going to be able to do that.
Not about talking about it.
It's about admitting it in public,
in front of a bunch of strangers at a
comedy club where everyone's drinking and
what percentage of the population
is asking a lot of the assholes
it's asking. I am very curious
in that moment. I know once,
you know, once I just wanted to
just start clapping in the middle,
you know, I had a great one. I was,
I, I don't remember where it was.
I remember what, what, how
the subject got to this,
but some woman in the audience
yelled out something about anal sex.
You know about either not liking
it or liking it. I don't remember,
but I remember something like I go,
that is a very rare that someone would
yell out, you know about anal sex.
You would want to keep that
like PR probably pretty private.
That could be potentially embarrassing.
Like, like I'll give you an example.
Like how many women here like taking it
in the ass and I thought in a couple of
actually clapped and yelled and I was
thinking any girl who would clap and yell
when that question comes up,
how many women like taking in the ass?
Like that's a girl who
really likes to say yes.
I mean she's completely comfortable
with it when she's like, look,
I'm the girl on that one.
If you look at for that one
out of a hundred that asked
for it who she is, right?
You know, if you don't know what you like,
how are you going to be happy in life?
And then you got to put
that message out there.
Well that assholes not filling itself.
You need to,
you need to be a hawker.
You gotta hop your own ass.
You got to let everybody know
you are that special person. Yes.
Rare person that likes guys. You're
afraid to even try it with your wife.
You know you could go 20 years and
then all of a sudden maybe on your 50th
anniversary you try to stick in
her ass and she's like, thank you.
Yeah. She was always almost bringing it
up but pulled back out of embarrassment.
He,
if he wanted and he would have tried it.
I'm not going to tell him I
want to fucking the ass. Gladys,
tell him you want it in
the ass now for 20 years.
I just don't think hockey would like that.
I don't think he'd respect maybe while
she goes to Harvey's fucking laptop,
but it's all bookmarks or teen in Ash,
DP it ass ass to mouth.
Screensavers just looks like a spider.
So fucking close up of it.
Dirty ass all outside soc one
of those like expanded those,
those but socks where someone just has a,
an exploded asshole,
which by the way,
never saw until I saw the internet.
Never knew that that was a thing.
Is it like a post anal sex than what
you just just swollen things stuffed in
your ass or your ass comes out like a,
like an unrolling juke clam.
It's horrible. No, that
was just different things.
It's unbelievable what people do.
They're buttholes these days. Yeah.
It's one tier.
That's the new frontier.
I talked to a friend of mine
who got divorced and he's a,
he's a comedian and he's got, you know,
he's got enough celebrity where he can,
and he said, Greg, they all want it the
ass now. He goes, it's fucking crazy.
He's like, I was never into ESX sex. And
now it's like, it's just what you do.
Wow. Yeah. Those kids today,
they're nuts. Absolutely nuts.
Here's you guys stuff is
nuts in there. Yes. Yeah.
How did he know he liked that?
I would be figured that out.
I think people just get bored.
They just get bored and they just do
whatever they can do. You know, they just,
after you do a certain amount of porn,
I mean,
I would imagine if you've
done porn for like 10 years,
just the thought of just having regular
sex, it's probably so boring to you. Yeah.
You know,
that's when they want to like put on
flippers and shit and fucking snorkels and
fucking in the tub and they would, they
want to just do ridiculous shit. Yeah.
They want to put pinwheels on their
nipples and put a bullet, you know,
one of those target signs on their ass
hole and have the guy run across them
because they're artists. You
know everybody, no matter
what you do for a living,
you should feel like there's a level
at which you can do it as an artist.
And I think there are porn stars
that really wanna like Bella Donna.
I think they really want to actually do
something that intro that creative for
them. Maybe it's possible
pregnant porn. Come on. Yeah,
pregnant porn and probably many things
up her ass while pregnant. Many. Yeah,
she,
she won best double anal one.
Oh
No, she wants single anal
twice. Oh, like I can see us.
Yeah. I was thinking, man,
that's probably one of the toughest
jobs for people to forget you from.
Like, say like if you were the host
of like American bandstand, you know,
and you were on TV for a long
time doing American bandstand,
you know you could quit and millions of
people saw you on American bandstand and
within a decade nobody would really
hold it against you that you were on
American Pan Stan. They, they
don't want to find you by that job.
But if you're a chick that's been
involved in multiple gang bangs with these
huge dicks and just fucking lube all
over you and guys making you gag and your
Mascara's running like that almost
never leaves you were a woman did almost
never leaves Tracy Lord might be the
only one that got close to escaping. Yup.
She got clothes.
She got in mainstream movies and,
and she turned out to be
pretty intelligence as she
would go on shows music too,
I think. Yeah, I think she
was like producing music.
Debbie Harry, I believed it.
Porn but Kim Kardashian from
the, no, from, from blondie.
Blondie. Really not positive,
but I believe she did porn
or was a or was a hooker.
Well, the sex tape thing is the
most amazing loophole like that.
You could just say,
I didn't know how that got out there
and then I remember they were doing that
for awhile. Oh yeah. I mean
like, especially like Kim
Kardashian and Paris Hilton.
That was like Pam Anderson because
the one, but she was already famous.
Oh you mean getting famous
that way? Oh yeah. Right.
I mean her and Tommy Lee was in Goddamn
Motley Crue. All right. You know,
he probably leaked it just to show her
his giant Dick. It was really hard.
It was really, they really like,
I don't care who you are as a guy.
You see that video. You feel really
bad about yourself? Not really.
I'll tell you why. Cause it's kind of
skinny. It doesn't have a lot of girth to,
okay.
It's not like a,
like there's certain dudes like Lexington
steels that his name, the porn guy,
he's got a dick that just doesn't
even look like it could be real.
Like the bar has been raised so high.
Like everybody like wants to go
with John Holmes all the time.
Especially guys in our age
bracket that was going to go,
the guy's got a dick like John Holmes.
Let me tell you something.
John Holmes barely has a big Dick
compared to some of these dudes. Yeah.
I mean his dick is big,
but that's like average big.
You think there's anything they
can do to make them bigger?
Is there like steroids evolution?
It's just finding big stars are evolving.
Just like the football players
are involved, right? Right. Yeah.
They're giant Dick dudes now in silicone
and they haven't been being blocked.
What? And they inject silicone. Do they
do that? Is that true? Wait a minute.
Do you know this for a fact?
A hundred percent do pull up the
letter we've already talked goes,
go get some links.
Injecting silicone in your deck.
I don't think that's
a common practice son.
That makes you dick all lumpy and shit.
It's actually used a lot
more than you think. Wow.
How do you know how
many ducks he inspected?
Kids got into bed and talked about
this a lot during the spectrum,
so well that means it's real.
Well long as we talked about it.
A man been six years injecting
silicone in his penis.
Well, of course there's instances. I'm
just wondering if the porn stars do it.
Yeah. I don't think that's
what's going on, dude.
Those dudes just have giant Dicks,
but that's not what's going on.
These guys have big decks. It's not
making your dick look like their deck.
It's just not. They have giant dicks.
If they do something to it, maybe,
but these dudes you want, they're limping.
They have these giant fucking dicks.
My English, you can find a
link you, there's tons of them.
I just can't really show you.
We'll just do an article or
something that says what they do.
I can show you by block putting your
logo ups and no one can see it except us.
Okay.
I like to see CSI do a fucking
dude.
This is a porn site,
guys sucking guys dicks on a porn site
that's not show proof that they're
shooting. Dude, if it was something
that they did all the time,
you could find a Google result of it.
Yeah. They're porn like porn stars.
Inject silicone into Dick's to make them
larger. Find that and then come to us.
You know, let a really big Dick. Ooh,
I bet he dead Dick Daughter Mary.
He used to do fucking 15 minutes.
I'd have big as Dick West.
I wait.
That's right. And he was
this, he was this guy who is,
he had to be in his sixties when he pulled
that up. Pull it up so we can read it.
What does it say?
Silicone Penis pumping parties
are a thing and there are no good.
Okay. I gotta read this on my
laptop where I can read it.
Silicone illegal penis pumping parties
are becoming increasingly popular.
Legal not to be in the copy button.
Oh,
you have to have a license for a fucking
silicone penis pumping party. Your,
your back. Applying for a license
for silicone penis pumping,
party pumping parties involved.
One person injecting nonsurgical
silicone into another person's body. Uh,
usually the silicone comes from items
found in your local hardware store like
flicks, fix a flat tire.
Oh, and they inject it. Boy,
you better really enjoy that
night. They use pumping party. Uh,
women in the past have used
pumping parties to enhance
the sizes of their butts.
But lately more and more men have been
doing it to their penises. Oh my God.
I've heard about women
getting, getting, you know,
they go to like Spanish Harlem and they
go to like a store front upstairs and
they inject cock and the,
and then it petrifies and
they've got these, oh my God.
Hard Lips. All right, Jeremy,
show you actual guy that has silicone
in his dick from a porn video.
Got a sensor it for the home people.
Okay. They're saying it doesn't work.
If there was a legitimate
method for penile linkedin,
Johnson and Johnson or Pfizer would
have bought it up and made billions and
billions of dollars worldwide. The fact
that they don't need that doesn't exist.
Like, so what they're saying though
is this is not, so that's Celine bro.
You got the wrong wrong substance.
That guy has sailing in his balls.
That's a common thing that they do
too. Yeah, we get, we get the video.
It's just salt water.
Um,
so let they're saying is that people are
idiots and that they get together and
they shoot salient in their dicks,
but these are the type of people
that they're nuts. I mean,
there's people that cut themselves and
put horns in their head and this is not
like something's porn stars do to make
their dicks bigger. What's his face?
You're saying also that doesn't work? Your
friend, uh, the porn star guy that, that,
that did rear tire at night that did rear
factor, uh, Steven Saint, Saint Croix,
he's the one that told,
also talked about it.
We've talked about it many
times on different podcasts
before. It's supposedly,
it is a thing in the industry that
people pumped their dick up with.
Like the shit.
I can't imagine that it would work though.
It doesn't make any sense that it
would make it look, I'm telling you,
if you see Lexington, steels Dick, and I'm
not saying go look for it, but you will.
And if you do, you're going
to go, that ain't fake.
That is not a big fake siliconed
up Weirdo Dick. Like a fake lip.
That's a dude with a giant Dick and he's
the only one of many the Johnny Holmes.
My point was that the Johnny Holmes
referenced that we had when we were kids,
that's no longer the benchmark.
These guys have way bigger
dicks than John Holmes.
John Holmes was in one of
those gang bangs. Those guys,
he would look like a guy with a big deck.
That's it.
They all have big dicks skies of
giant dicks. Some of these guys,
you can't believe that they
can own a dick that big,
like what do they do with it when
they're not using it? They laugh.
Here's all day laughing at the fucking
the goodness of the world has given them.
Here's an article on your tango.
It's an interview with a male porn
stars and one of the things he says,
sometimes dudes can't get it up,
which is a problem on a porn set.
No surprise there,
but apparently you could build
up tolerance to injection
erection enhancers like
Viagara they solution inject your Dick.
Yes.
With a needle with more in intense liquid
medication that works incidentally and
leaves your underside of your cock
filled with needle holes. Yeah,
but you're talking about the wrong
stuff. Yeah. This is around forever.
They've been doing that forever. I think
it's the, there's, in the old days,
they used to do it, I believe with
testosterone, like someone said,
they inject testosterone right in the
base there. Dick and their dick would go
so crazy,
act in the penis and just
start doing pushups on its own.
You don't even have to move.
Oh my come and jacked and Dick,
I would use Pillsbury,
a Dell and mine doesn't,
and check off and have
a croissant come out.
Are you cooking it in kind of
fucking how hot does you, Dick,
do you know? That's a thing
that people do. I was like,
why do I have a yeast infection again,
specifically
does the thing that people do where they
drive for a long trips and they'll put
food on their grill or on
the engine block. Ah, oh,
like wrap it in aluminum foil,
put it on the engine block and cook it
as they're driving and then pull over and
and eat the food. That's
genius. Yeah, and it works.
Of course they like you can take a
the tilapia little slice of butter,
some garlic salt, put that bitch
up in, they're folded. Nice.
Put it on your engine block and then the
other one you roll up some asparagus.
Yeah, put that also in the aluminum
foil and then drive a couple of hours.
Pull over and have a nice dinner.
I wonder how long it would take to,
do you need a cookbook?
Somebody should come up with
a cookbook for cooking times.
And what part of the
engine to put it on to pay.
If you have a v six cooking
time is only 12 minutes. Right?
You gotta have a Prius. It's four
and a half hours. Doesn't get high.
Have you ever fucking old Mustang?
He would get it off in five minutes,
hit the gas once and eat those like,
like an old,
like a gt three 50 those
fucking things got so hot.
Those old cars got so hot.
I had this,
I had this Volkswagen rabbit back when
I was going from New York to Boston
pretty much every week. Wow. I had a
Volkswagen rabbit and it, it, it the,
they used to have the starter right next
to the engine block and so it would get
heated up and if I stopped like at
the Mass Pike, you know, rest area,
it wouldn't start again because
it was so fucking hot to start.
It was just like incapacitated and I
have to wait like 40 minutes to start the
car again. So I would just leave the
car running in the rest areas. Whoa.
That's up bitch.
I used to have a,
one of the things I loved about having a
manual transmission as I didn't eat the
starter that I could uh, pop rock
ledge. That was a big thing, man.
I wonder if I could do that with a new
car. Does that work on new cars too?
I had is probably all
kinds of safety things,
but I wonder if it works on new cars.
I should try it on.
It is a huge upside of having a standard.
Oh, it was giant. I'd loved it because I,
my car ran out of batteries
before I forgot the lights. Yeah.
I left the lights on and all I did was
get that. But I did it backwards once.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know how the fuck I did it.
A backwards into reverse or backwards in
the reverse. Backwards in reverse works.
What it works great in first.
First is where it really works.
All your car is standard
that you have now?
No, no. I have a an m three
that's not a standard. Mm.
But that's my commuter car now.
I'm trying to think of,
I did do it backwards or if I rolled
down a hill backwards and then turned
around in the intersection and pulled
it out. I did it so many fucking times.
I don't remember. But I had this Audi
Fox. It was such a piece of shit.
Those were pieces of such a piece of shit.
But I love that car.
That car has a special car for me.
Special car and my memory. Yeah.
Cause that was like my independence car.
Those was the first car that I got when
I like moved out of my parents' house
and it's the first car that I got,
there was a small car that I could drive
around in and had cool kind of European
thing going on. Two front wheel
drive, manual transmission.
But it was such a hunk of
shit died all the time.
I was always popping the
clutch on that fucker.
I think it was a Volkswagen at some point
and then it switched sides cause Audi
and Volkswagen where like
the same company. Really.
I thought I thought cotter had a
Volkswagen Fox. Maybe his was an Audi Fox,
but I had, I had that.
That's my baby. Oh yeah.
That's nice man. That's,
that looks like a uh, uh,
I didn't have that year
and I had a copper one. It
was copper colored. I think.
I want to know if it was a two door
or four door, like a month show.
I think it was a four door.
Is this your first car? No,
it was my first like independent cars.
Like when I was independent,
when I wasn't living with my
parents anymore. I had this car,
I think I bought it from one of
my mom's friends or something too.
I can't remember how the fuck I got it,
but it was like one of those cars where,
look,
let me just drag this piece of shit around
for a while because I had been really
into cars since I've, like,
I've first got my license,
I was loved American muscle cars.
That's what I loved.
I love like old Chevelles and barracudas
and challengers and those kinds of cars.
I just loved them, man. It just, other
cars to me were just transportation.
Like I got it.
Yeah.
I know that you want to get a VW
because that was exactly what I had.
It was a two door. That's exactly what I
had. It was like a copper color though.
Like a little darker. But um, but
that was the first car that I had.
There was like, this is just going to
get me where I want to go. Like this,
what freedom that is.
When you were inside that car and you
realize like I'm in a capsule and it's
fucking mind and it takes me where
I want to go. That's powerful. Yeah.
When you're young and it's the first
time you get to just go wherever you want
and you've been taking susses and walking,
I'll walk to your house
seeing an hour now it's like,
I'll see you in two minutes and then
we'll go buy beer and sit behind a fucking
bleach. That same car? No. Oh wait,
no. That looks like a hatchback. It's not
the same car at all. See Sprint. Yeah,
it's totally different company.
Different names. Well No,
I can you mind worse research?
Google car fit the model and for some
reason that just got mixed in with your
cars. Oh No. Why cars? It sucked.
That you won't don't want in 2014. And
how did, how did you afford the car?
You work for it. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't remember.
Um,
cause I don't remember what year it was,
but I thought during those days it's
probably a mix of construction work and
probably delivering newspapers still then.
Yeah,
I was delivering newspapers
even before I had the, the Audi.
I started newspapers like right out of
high school. I did it for like four years.
I might have even done it while in
high school for a while it was just the
greatest gig ever.
Did you throw them out?
The it to us and the driver's door and
it depended on where I was driving.
Would you ever stop and get out because
you made a bad throat? Yes. I stopped,
got out if I made a bad throw and there
are certain houses that they demanded
that you put it inside their door now,
which is really annoying.
Did they tip you those
people? Um, some of them were,
some of them I didn't mind it if there
were old folks just didn't want to get up
and walk all the way down the steps.
I did it for like,
there was this old lady that was super
sweet and I always did it for her and she
didn't ask for it. No,
she's a little too old.
Couple of years I missed her by a couple
of won it in the ass. Never had it.
They didn't do it in the ass in the 80s
pro was that asshole is as tight as her
vagina relation when she was
17 she's waiting, just waiting.
It's not camped.
It's definitely not kept up.
Well definitely flavored smoked and you
know with that arthritis tastes like
that's right. And she's not
getting a good wife coming back.
They're either early finger,
one finger in the door.
No one had anything but toilet paper
back then. And even in porn girls,
I'd Harry asshole's back then. I remember
that. And pouring, there was just,
it was a jungle. They just left it
alone. There was no trimming. No.
And then one brave gow shaved the whole
cooter and from then on out it was no
turning back. Now it's weird if you see
it. Have you even been, well I guess not,
but have you like lately if you see it,
it's kind of like what the fuck? No,
that's your, that's the thing. Now that's
the thing is, is retro bushes. Bushes.
Yeah. She wasn't making a
comeback now. Huge Bushes.
But you know a little bit of jungle.
Yeah. A little bit of jungle forestry,
just a little bit of rain forest park.
Just a little a triangle of green in the
town square. It's a little something.
We'll swap and make it interesting when
people try to change it up every now and
then with everything. I mean remember when
they tried to bring bell bottoms back?
There was a time we're dudes, we're in
bell bottoms. Skin didn't last long.
It was only a couple of months,
but people were just trying. Yeah.
You know and people accused me of that
with the fanny pack. But I tell you this,
first of all, I never stopped
wearing a fucking fanny pack ever.
So you can't tell me that.
I'm trying to bring it back
because it never went away.
Is it that always been fuck it back.
Matthew mcconaughey was at a baseball
game wearing one and he was seeing the
virtues of the fanny pack.
I sell out of them on higher primate.com
sell out of them every month.
I hate having shit in my pockets.
I love the fan. You want one?
I got one for Ya right here. Jamie. Get it
for him. Oh, I love it. It's leather. No,
my kids laugh at me because I have
one bit of ripped apart. Yeah.
See that's a decent one.
But the roots one,
I got the routes one from dice roots is
the best fucking company. Great Company.
Good bags. Yeah. They um,
they dice came in sweatpants
go fanny pack. Oh. And
so he comes in with this,
look at that.
This fucking fanny pack.
It's a sweet fucking to
legit pockets in the front,
high quality, everything.
Gray latch, fuck them.
Excellent latching system.
And it's really high quality.
The best quality fanny pack I could find.
And so I had my higher primate leg logo.
If you look on one of the pockets,
she though the chimp logo with
the light bulb above his head.
That's the higher primate logo. So
I had it in him, Boston, whatever,
with pressed whatever it is into the
leather leather. Oh fuck. Yeah. Yeah.
Those are high quality men.
But if you were one of those,
like it's so convenient when you
go to the airport. My God. Yeah.
Because when you go to the airport,
it's such a bitch to take everything out
of your fucking pockets and put it back.
And chicks don't have to do that.
If they just lay down their
purse and walked through
their side and they're good,
you know, like, cause I like my glasses.
They're sitting on the table right now.
I'll probably forget them.
That happens to me every fucking day.
This way I stick them right
inside my fanny pack. Tao Pao.
The phone slips right in there. When
it vibrates, it vibrates, right?
All your Dick reach down,
touch it, pull it on me.
You wait until it's like four or
five rings in, then you pull it out.
I just put this, my point is that
this isn't like the bell bottom.
This is functional as fuck.
It's like the most functional way
to carry your shit around ever.
And the reason why people don't do it is
because they're worried that they look
bad. Is it a conversation starter?
Do you find? Yes, most certainly is.
Yes. People go right on, man. I go,
yeah, that's right. Fuck everybody.
Fuck Rosey Greer. And the 70s started
wearing dude carrying a purse. Teddy,
that giant fucking linebacker who's going
to say shit to him? Nobody. Exactly.
Yeah, you don't need a backpack.
Doesn't even have to handle yet. Right,
but the real deal is oh,
backpacks better than a purse and
you're allowed to wear a backpack.
Like if a guy has a backpack on and
you know you run into some friends,
one of them happens to be a girl.
Nobody gives you a hard time.
But if you had a fucking purse
on, it'd be like, what's up bitch?
What are you doing with that purse?
Holy Shit is that shit now the fuck
is wrong with you, right? We usually,
you don't have a woman anywhere near you.
You're just walking around with this and
if you are a guy and you have a purse,
you got to carry it like this.
Like out to the side as if it's a head
that you just cut off with the fucking
sword. Like it's smelly garbage.
You're bringing out to the curb.
I'm carrying this because I'm going to
get some pussy at the end of this fucking
journey. I got this in my hand
and when I bring it back to her,
I'm going to fuck the life out of her
like that free second I holidays cause
another second I'm inside
of her skull with my chef.
And plus you could do like
some good shoulder exercises.
Just do some hand offs as you walk with
the person because a lot of chicks that
fucking heavy persons,
you know you've got a lot of shit done.
The bigger the pitch that the bigger
the purse, the crazier the woman also.
That's so true, right? Yeah.
But those chicks that have
like little tiny like clutches,
those are those the chicks that could just
fucking, they'll come over your house.
Fuck you in the art. Take care. I've
got to hit the airport. That's it.
Those chicks travel light.
They a handy wipe in there
for the undercarriage.
Otherwise it's just a boarding pass.
Give it a little fucking one of
those, the sanitary things. Go to the,
you know those uh, wipes. Chiro
wipes for eating roots. Yeah.
Pigs you get it would read
you the little white.
It looks the same. Yeah.
Fuck aids. Let it go.
Let it go and get on that plane.
World travelers,
some people do travel like that.
Dot.
Merera buys all his underwear and socks
everywhere he goes. That's true out. Yeah.
Throws them out. That sounds like a an
effort though to find a place that sells.
Not really anywhere and it just pulls
in somewhere. When he gets there,
get some socks. What is he renting a
car and I don't know. I got the Gig.
I don't know. I mean a Betty does
in some places for sure. You know,
but I always red card. You rent a car
when you go places. Rarely. Rarely.
I go to the hotel and I just hold up
your trap press for few days. I know.
You keep telling me I gotta break
some on the right way. We do it, man.
We do it so different now with
Uber, you don't need a, that's true.
But then you got some
crazy dude driving around.
It's probably barely been
fucking profiled. The barely
check that guy out. Yeah,
right. You know, all of a sudden you run
out of gas. Robert Downey Jr with a purse.
It's probably, it's probably his
wife's purse. Yeah. He's Robert Downey.
Motherfucking junior and he's got $1
billion. She doesn't give a fuck. Yeah,
but that, but the purse hanging around
the arm seems like a pain in the ass.
That seems like you're stuck with your
arm like that though. It's so good.
Exercise. Good for the arm muscles. Right.
Put a Kettlebell on the other one on it.
First Kettlebell in it. I have a bowling
ball, um, case that I carry with me.
When I go on the road,
I bring a kettle bell on it.
I throw like a to really throw 50
pound Kettlebell in that bitch.
Check it shot out. Yeah. I'm
seriously on a roller and everything.
So you can do kettle bells when
you get to the hotel. Otherwise,
what are you gonna get? A kettle bell.
Wow. It's hard. Hard to get a kettle bell.
Have you ever tried one? The water
ones where you just pump up with water.
It doesn't,
not strong enough for this one.
You get a feed that that needs to be fed.
This is Ken.
This water's not going to need
something much larger than water.
Water is not heavy enough. You need
metal. There you go son. Look at that.
Brian's working out. Yeah, it's
kid. He was shaking a little bit.
It's some hotels have great gyms.
When a hotel is a great gym,
it's a godsend because you
don't have to go anywhere.
It's right there in the building
when they have great 24 hour gyms.
That's amazing. Oh, can you do that?
You do the midnight workout. I love it.
No shift or shows. I love after
show, wait lived in session.
You go for a while. Yeah.
You know why I do it?
Cause I don't want to do it because
after shows I want to just do nothing.
So every now and then I like to exercise
that part of me that doesn't want to do
something, Huh? Yeah.
I think it's important to do yet I would
just worked in Tampa and they had a gym
around the corner that was like,
you know,
triathlon or like what are the people
that drag type tire. Fucking Dji.
They had giant tractor tires you
could push and change. You could pull.
It was wild.
They was like no pussy machines at all.
None of my machines are they.
Isn't it funny that all that stuff used
to be called work right? That was what
people used to do. You had to pick up
chains. If you worked in a fucking ship,
climb a ladder. Yeah. If you worked in a
factory that made tires yet a flip tires,
it'll move them mean now everybody's like,
you know,
I'm getting a crossfit workout in them
hitting the tire with a sledgehammer.
Why don't you do some honest work that
that all you're wasting all that sledge
hammer movement. You could be breaking
rocks in the pen, right? This crates,
you stack crates over in the corner
and then you restack them in the other
corner. You remember? That was what we
always saw in in penitentiary moves.
Dudes would break rocks. I remember
that. Yup. Was that, is that real?
That still they still do
that? They break rocks. Yeah.
I would think the last thing you would
want as a bunch of inmates with insane
cardio that had been
breaking rocks all day. Yeah.
Cause if you have a fucking sledgehammer
and you're swinging that bitch all day
break and rocks, my God, are you going to
get in insane shape? You're backing it.
And if you punch somebody, George Foreman
used to do that. He used to chop wood.
That was like one of his exercises.
My neighbor does that every night.
It's sucks truck knowing he just sits
there and shops would all night long and
it's, and it's loud but he has this
humongous thing that you just like,
it doesn't split because it's just a
humongous like so he does it just for
finding out, Huh? Yeah. My uh,
my doctor digs holes in
his yard. I go, I go,
what do you do for exercise?
Cause he doesn't, he doesn't, he,
he's a black belt in martial arts to
some kind of martial art. But I'm a,
I go did you that
anymore? He was like, Dad,
it's too much strain on my body
because he's in his sixties I go,
so what do you do for workouts?
Because I dig holes in my yard.
I go out in the yard and I just do rope.
I just do yard work. Start digging holes.
Yeah. I go, do you want to dig these
holes? Is there a purpose for him?
He goes sometimes and sometimes it's
just to dig a hole, you know? No,
he's a nice guy, but he said that
that's like a great way of uh,
it's a great like that's a manual labor
that's like really robust for the body
because you're digging into that dirt,
you're forcing it in with your legs,
taken it up, you're hoisting it up and
then boom, and then it is like, he goes,
if you look at the motion of like
digging a hole, he's like all of that.
It's like an excellent workout.
Yeah. It's like you're forcing your,
using your legs, using your arms,
using your shoulders and your back.
You're digging, you're bending
down, you're picking it up.
It's all these muscles are engaged.
So when it's an activity,
then you will push yourself further. Then
if you were just lifting a dead weight,
there's no creativity. There's no
beginning, middle and end to it.
But when you're shoveling or even if
you're busting up stones, there's like,
I'm going to bust this fucking stone up.
But I would think busting up stones
would fuck your face up and your body up.
You could hit with shrapnel and shit.
You'd probably get cut here.
I would have your answer to
death by the end of the day.
You'd have to have some shit in your ears
and you know that you know the handles
getting splinters on it. They're
not giving you good, good hammers.
They'll probably give you gloves or
anything they give you. Maybe, maybe,
but I got news for you. Even with
gloves, you're going to get blisters.
You swinging a hammer all day,
a sledge hammer,
breaking rocks and you're doing
it five days a week or whatever.
They make those guys work.
See, they need to combine, uh,
the gym with actual industry.
Like what if you really did need rocks
broken up, bring them to Gold's gym,
dump 'em out back. Have people
come out and cross train by slant,
by hitting the rocks, hookup all
the cardio machines to a generator.
So you're getting the
electricity out of it.
Turn the gym into a working
energy and production machines.
Do you know how much cardio you'd have
do to generate any energy?
Like is that right energy to like power
a phone while you're jogging would be
very difficult. You couldn't even get,
keep the lights going in the gym. Yeah,
I mean May, no, no, no, no, no, no.
With the music plan, the TV's on and all
the fluorescents on good fucking luck.
Solar.
You could do it with solar,
but the amount of force that you would
have to do like on an elliptical machine
just to keep your iPhone running. I
don't know if you could do it. Wow.
I really think that your iPhone would
require at least as much as you were doing
if you were like really
fucking hoofing it,
unless they made a super efficient
system. But I don't know, man.
I don't know. I just, I would
think that if that was the case,
there would be all sorts of mechanical
work arounds for electricity.
You know,
think that that would be something that
someone would have thought of a long
time ago.
If you could imagine if you could get
your day's worth of electricity all by
doing a 20 minute session on your lip
tickle machine every day. So every day,
not only did you force yourself to get
a good exercise in to start your day,
but when you bank it like that,
it stores electricity and it powers
your entire house for the day.
Air Conditioning,
that would be bad ass.
And eventually we get to the point where
we all have like where they get ion
small enough where everyone's got a
battery pack, you've got a fanny pack,
it's got a battery in it and you've got
to work out in the morning to charge
that mother fucker. And then when you go
to work, your computer plugs in there.
It's just got a giant plug
and then you fill it yourself.
If you don't have enough
juice at the end of the day,
you don't fucking work on your computer.
Yeah. Well you would, you would need
that energy. It's like in a way,
that's kind of what people used to have
to do when they were chopping wood. Yeah.
It's like you had to go out
and chop that fucking wood up,
otherwise you didn't have wood to burn.
Like there's a show that I watched
some times. Um, friends. Dot.
I don't watch curious George Frazier.
That's my favorite. No, it's not.
Um, I know it's Frazier thing.
Never got it. Never understood it.
I'd watch it for five minutes ago.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's classic Classic Sitcom formula.
Get one character who is exactly
the same as the other character,
and then just watch the conflict arise
and that it's,
well,
it's Frazier's one of the weird sitcoms
where people don't talk about it. Yeah.
Like that was a big Goddamn said.
Come for a long years or some shit.
Nobody talks about, here's another one.
Right. I don't want a ton of enemies too.
Here's another one. Ready for this John
Larroquette show. How long was that?
I don't remember exactly
exactly a long time. Right.
You don't hear about it? Lenny Clarke
was on it. Lenny Clarke was on the set.
I'm right down the s like like one sound
stage over when I was on news radio,
it was a news radio was on one side.
Joey Lawrence was a next to us and Joey
Lawrence would sit in his car and he
would open his doors up of his
car. It's some crazy car, you know,
he's super rich and he would crank his
sound system with his songs plan and he
would sit there.
Yes and like fucking rock out to his size.
Be fucking kid was like 18 right.
The kid was 18 and you had a Ferrari
or something ridiculous. Big Mercedes.
I mean he had a ton of cars.
I mean he was unbelievably wealthy and
he would play his music and Dave Foley
took great amusement in this day.
Fully loved it.
He was like the Lawrence boys out
there playing his music again.
He would come in and he goes, he
seems to quite like us, his own songs,
same wave to him and he, there he is
nothing.
My Love camp fix.
Here's this Easter before Bieber,
all his clothes are way too big
is beautiful. Look at that hair,
man. I didn't have hair
like that when I had hair.
All my hair, like I hadn't lost a piece
of hair. I didn't have hair like that,
but he was a, he would play this in
his, in his thing right next to it.
So right next to him
was Greg Geraldo direct.
Greg Geraldo show was,
uh,
was or am I be fucking
up the timeline here.
I think Geraldo might've
been first season.
Joey Lawrence might've been second season,
but Geraldo show was on there as well.
And then right over here was the John
Larroquette show with Lenny Clarke and
we're all on the same fee. We can watch
them rehearse so we could watch like,
and I would watch the rehearsals
and lyric. It was such a Dick.
He would yell at all the other actors
and fucking see that, oh my God,
he was a dick.
I used to watch him yell at Lenny.
And Lenny is a big fucking guy and Lenny
is a guy who's been in a lot of fights.
He's done his share of below and he
will punch you in your fucking face.
But he didn't because he was on the show
with this guy and he's like pictogram
an episode. I tell him, John
fucking relaxed. You're on TV.
Why are you so fucking
stressed? You know? Yeah.
But I would watch him yell at the cast
or throw his fucking script and get all
pissed off. And you know
that. And that happens on set.
It just as people get all fucking tents
that work together all the time and it's
so much stress involved and sometimes
people blow off at each other. Yeah,
well,
and you're getting paid so much money
that you start to internalize that what
you're doing is actually that important.
Like the money really shouldn't be
that high for what you're doing.
And so you start to feel like you really
should be giving more and it should be
better. And it's still a sitcom.
It's not supposed to be any better.
Well it's also, it was the John Leora cat
show. So it's his show had his name on,
he was on what it was at night before
that. This is after or it, right. Yup.
Yup.
How many seasons did that go Brian?
I would say only three cause
I barely remember it would
say only three Google it.
But then my more, what
is it, indication decade.
I bet it went to syndication.
I would guarantee you did at least four
and Nightcore he had the kind of Gig
where he just showed up, nailed a couple
scenes and went home. Yeah. For 10 years.
Yeah. Um, but it's one of those shows that
was on TV when, when news radio was on,
it was like a big show and no
one talks about, it's weird.
Right? How many seasons?
Four went from 93 to 96.
Yep. So four seasons.
Yeah. Probably do a hundred episodes.
Yup. I think that's what they did.
And then they got out, banged out 25 a
year. Well I think isn't the magic number.
100,
that's when they can syndicate.
That's why news radio never really got
to a hundred those like our joke is that
we never, we never quite made it. You
didn't get to a hundred oh we got some 98.
Oh that's hilarious. Yeah, but
it's syndicated anyway. Right.
So like they didn't need
a hundred syndicated,
but it was an inside joke
with us that like Yep,
that's us fucking never quite made it.
Dallas short became famous
after it was off the air.
That's when it really became famous. I
mean it, it became famous when Phil died,
you know, but before Phil died, uh,
it wasn't like a hit show cause
we moved around nine times.
That's a real number.
Your time slot nine times over five years.
And this is pre internet.
That's right. I remember that.
You know when you all over the place
where it was and any bad ones like Friday
night we got terrible ones.
I don't remember where it was.
I remember it was there was Monday for
awhile and there was Tuesday and I think
Sunday,
but we never got Thursday.
Thursday was like the big night we were
on Thursday once we were like number two
and I was like friends and then
us and we were like, oh my God,
this could happen every week. But
it never happened again. Yeah,
it's with the spot, the sign,
the sign, um, or the um,
time slot that you're in is so
important. Time slots, everything.
And like there was a lot of shows that
would be like friends Seinfeld and that
show would be in the middle,
you know?
And they would call it the shit
sandwich spot. That's what Paul said,
just to call up because it's
like these amazing shows.
And then in between these amazing
shows would be like sex in the city.
Different roles. Jonathan Silverman.
Yeah. That show the single side guy.
And those shows would be unwatchable
but they would be sandwiched in between
genius shows and so everybody would watch
them. So everybody wanted those slots.
Well I think they launched third rock in
that spot too, didn't they? I don't know.
I don't remember. I think they might
have launched it there and then take,
cause that's their goal is that's the,
that's where,
that's where they plant the seed.
They let it grow and then they
transplanted hopefully to a Tuesday or a
Wednesday.
Right.
That becomes an anchor for other shows
and they can do that now way better
because people can alert people to, at
the time slots changed. But back then,
no one knew what the fuck was going on.
And once you had TV guide, you know,
you didn't know when the time slot
was, so we'd moved slots. Also,
you're taking advantage of the delete in,
you know,
they're just going to Thursday night
must see TV people put it on at eight
o'clock and they turned
it off at 10 o'clock yeah.
And it was a tradition for some strange
reason, like a Thursday night tradition,
mostly because there was
great shows like Seinfeld,
I think cheers was the Thursday
night show. Yes, originally. Right.
So it's always been traditionally
their spot. There's a great book,
Warren Littlefield Road
called top of the rock.
That's the history of Thursday night.
Must See TV. He talks about just,
I mean you realize how
random things happen.
Like the casting of friends could
have gone eight different ways.
Literally you have is
people test for a show.
So you've got three or four actors
going in for role in one day.
And the fact that they picked Jennifer
Aniston, the fact that they picked,
you know, they nailed that cast. It was
exact. I mean I was never into the show.
I never got it. But it is
apparently a very perfect balanced,
you know, ensemble cast. Yo, they
nailed it. They nailed the casting.
But the book tells you about how many
ways things could have blown over
contracts, what the reality
is. If they did it differently,
it probably still would have worked.
They would have found some
other talented people.
Maybe not a matter of those are the
only gyms they could have. Fine.
There's so many God damn talented
people that never get the chance.
That's the craziest thing about
acting is that you don't have like,
there's no recourse. Like if they
don't choose you, tough shit.
There's nothing else. It's like
a comic. You're undeniable.
You go up at the Improv and destroy than
someone who's got a sitcom deal goes on
after that and sucks their own dick.
There's nothing anybody could say.
It's like you can't deny that Greg for was
this funny. You just saw it. It's over.
He proved it. But if you're an
actor, good luck. Good fucking luck.
That's why they're so facetious.
That's twice.
There's so like there's so much
fakeness in the way they behave.
That's why there's so much
anxiety in the actor community.
Like their entire Gig is dependent
upon someone else's approval. Yeah.
When you meet Sitcom actress,
there's so positive and they so try to
make a connection with you and be your
friend and you always walk away
going, wow, that's a really good guy.
And then you realize that mother
Fucker, he's working, he's working.
If they have to work it,
if they don't work,
if there's any hint whatsoever
that you might be difficult,
they will move on to step two.
Who's the other guy brewing I'm in and
the other guy comes in, he give it to him,
you know it happens and cast. And then
once you make it, then they trust you.
I mean, you look at the
people. Exactly. You know,
you look at Kelsey grammar
or Julia Louise Dreyfus.
Like some people they just go
put them back in the camp fail.
It's just the writing's
bad. Yeah. Yeah. This I,
you know Ray Romano was the original guy
on my gig. Right, and news radio. Yeah.
They fired him during
the taping of the pilot.
So like this guy just doesn't
connect with America. Yeah. Leaves,
it goes off to do a giant
way more successful Sitcom.
Everybody loves Raymond in the title.
Not only are you wrong in firing him,
but in the title it says everybody
loves Raymond. Like you don't,
you didn't think that people liked him.
No. You're so wrong. He was so good.
He literally walked away from the job.
How often does that happen? Where they go,
we're only going to do 10 and I think
they talked him into 11 and then they
walked away like still with really
strong ratings. You mean seasons?
I think they did 10 and then they bought
another one. Wow. He did 11 seasons.
I think so.
Check it out Brian.
How much money is involved and own our
own show and being on 11th and a show
that by the way,
still in the air,
like that's Andrea Frasier or these
other shows that you flip through the
channels. You'll find everybody that
was Raymond on all the time. It's still,
I don't know. Does he own it to see you
have some ownership? Yes. Hold on sharp.
Yeah, without a doubt you can't have it.
I don't know about that Raymond show.
And he was like,
I remember I had a development deal the
same year he did when it was the Raymond
deal and his was minuscule.
I remember almost thinking like,
oh that's so fucking weird. That guy.
So funny. And like I know it was like a,
it was like a September development deals,
like the end of the season.
And he kind of crawled in and he,
he'd been doing Letterman,
so it was a deal with worldwide pants
and then they put them together with Phil
Rosenthal and it struggled to show strike.
No,
I don't think he had enough juice to get
ownership eventually. I'm sure he did.
Yeah. Eventually. I'm sure
they renegotiated it. Yeah,
I know he's insanely wealthy.
Nine seasons, nines, nine seasons.
Well, when I was, uh, you know,
I'm good friends with Kevin James
and when I was on news radio,
it was right when like rain,
I didn't have any tension because it was
actually a guy in between us that got
hired to do his gig and then that
guy got fired and then I got it.
So it wasn't like I was taken
over race spot, but uh, and Brian,
I'd always been friends and so we were
eating at Jerry's Deli and it was right
when he got it. I never seen a guy more
obsessed with getting things right.
Like we're all sitting there eating
dinner or lunch or whatever the fuck where
eating and ray would be like, um,
what if a guy comes in and he's like,
he's going through all of his bits,
like going through the thing like
he was [inaudible] no, no, no.
The bits like that, we're going
to happen on a sitcom. Oh,
like he was going through the beats. Like,
is it better or do you know? He's like,
had all these ideas and he was
just throwing them out like they,
they couldn't stay in his head.
He was so obsessed with getting it right
that it was like all day, every day.
It was on his mind.
You know,
I was working catch a rising star in
Princeton with uh, Tom, uh, Captain Viano,
Tom Paris. He changed his name to who
was like his wing man basically. Bianco,
right. Count to Bianco. Yeah.
Isn't that how you say it? Yeah,
he's like a photographer and he
was a writer on Ray. But anyway,
he came down and ray was,
Tom was opening for me and ray was taking
the train from New York to Princeton
to keep working on the pilot
with Tom. Wow. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
He works hard. Ben. He works well. He's
obsessive. Yeah. He funny, funny, funny.
I just played golf at this club that
he belongs to and I told me like,
ray Ya little obsessive out
here. Yeah. With Golf. Yeah.
Well Kevin to him and Kevin, everybody
knows she maniacs with golf. Really?
Kevin Plays Golf. Good. Yeah, I just
saw it last night. His brother, he,
he hurt his shoulder playing golf.
Didn't Gary did carry Valentine. Yeah,
just going crazy. He hit a shot out
of the rough was thick, rough. Any,
I guess the club got caught and he
ripped his fucking shoulder heart.
That can happen, Huh? Yeah.
I would imagine, you know,
if you hit something really hard and
all a sudden it stops. Right? Right.
Shoulder is a tough one. Man Shoulder
has a, it's a weird joint. Unlike a knee,
like a knee,
they can fix pretty good because knees,
it's fairly simple cause it only
hinges, you know, it goes up and down,
but shoulder has all this articulation
and movement and you'd have to apply
pressure in 360 degrees in any given time.
You're pushing up back forward.
I had shoulder surgery a
couple of years ago. Did you?
Well all the ligaments had worn
out and you know, we're, we're,
the clavicle comes together with it.
There's three bones that
come together right here.
And so they went in and they, they sawed,
they went in two spots arthroscopically.
They saw down each of the three bones a
little bit and it creates space and then
it causes, um, uh, tissue,
what do you call scar tissue,
which acts like a ligament. And
now my arm fucking 100%. Why?
I couldn't even lift it. And it was just,
I wore it out just from, did you tear it?
No. It was the life life of throwing
objects and being a, being a boy,
throwing things into big one man's
shoulder surgery for football players that
are quarterbacks and also for baseball
players. That's super common, man. Yeah.
There's something about throwing that's
just a lot of stress on the body. Yeah.
The good thing about boxing and uh,
those kinds of workouts as,
especially if you hit a bag,
you're hitting something.
So even though there's like
resistance at the end of it,
you're hitting something. So it's
not like the, the snap of like,
like missing things, right? The rowing
thing, when you try to grow things,
this is like experience sending and
you're starting behind yourself. Boxing.
Your hands are in front of you.
So you're,
you've got your bio bodyweight behind
everything you're dealing. Yeah.
And when you hit something
like the workout,
like if anybody wants a great workout,
get a God damn bag.
Get a heavy bag of you've got a garage
or a basement or something where we can
hang it or, or someplace that has
a bag that could work out it. Man.
It just fucking set your phone down
and time yourself for three minutes.
Go Hammer that fucker. Even if you have
shit technique, just keep hitting it.
Hit that fucker.
Three minutes.
You'll be amazed at how exhausted you
are and then how good you feel after you
feel so bad. I know. And it also,
you can do it if you're married,
just hit your wife.
No Bray Craig,
you've, I mean you need to
marry a heavy girl. You don't,
if you use like a buck 10 she's
one punch your workouts. So yeah,
you want like a one 50 with a good chin,
good stout chin.
Make some strong babies
and some anger issues.
So she pushes back this weekend I got
to drive a dodge challenger Hellcat.
That is going to be your next car. Really
told me that you wanted to get, yeah.
Going to want to get a challenger.
Yeah.
You're lucky you didn't get the old
challenges cause they're kinda shit boxes
but nailed it now.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Big as
the engine car. Oh nothing.
Just 707 horsepower.
Is that the biggest reduction and the
most powerful muscle car ever built?
Whoa. Exactly. Women will
never understand this. Greg,
I knew that you were
going to be here today,
so I was happy while I was driving it
that I'm going to get to talk to Greg
about this. What did it feel like?
This is what this is driving it.
Do you get cut and cut to way
towards the end of this video?
That was the beginning of it cuts away
towards the end when he's driving it
because for the first like 20 minutes
they just talk. It's pretty cool.
Did you punch it coming out of a turn?
Yeah.
Are the wheels do we beat the
shit out of this thing? Sorry,
dodge SRT only in good ways. We
just stomped on the gas a lot. Okay.
It was just a fun man
dots.
Well it's automatic that one is,
but they sell on a stick to,
you can buy an a stick.
You want to stick that visibility looks
better to my prom with the challenge and
was always the visibility.
It's kind of funky out of the
passenger side when you looking back,
that right corner is a little funky
but whatever. Let's just start at,
it's not that much.
It's like for $60,000 and I'm
telling you which is a lot of money,
but for that car for 707 horsepower and
the biggest production engine out there
and you're getting it for less than, it's
so comfortable. That's what's fucked up.
Like these cars,
like they figured out how to make the
suspensions and the seats and everything
where it's, it's like a Cadillac. I
swear to God, Dude, you'll be blown away.
I didn't even put it like
there's modes you can put it in.
You can put it in like track mode.
I didn't put it on track,
but look how awesome that Dan is.
Awesome.
Play that sound so you could hear it
when he's doing that because it sounds so
fucking good
for dodge. This is how cats, that
code name of the engine, right?
This is not even doing it justice
because he's inside of it with the camera
because we liked the name so much about
it and it was so fitting for the car.
Right? Right. Little bounce
on the back end. Dude.
It's so smooth. Drive it. It's
so comfortable because it's huge.
It's 4,000 pounds. It's not like
a little car. It's a Mustang.
This is designed to ruin the earth.
Okay.
You're supposed to take part and ruining
the earth with a smile on your face and
a fucking glass of Chivas Regal and your
hand smoking that Dunhill stomping on
the gas and you can see the tsunami
behind you as you out run it. Ah,
knowing you caused it.
Whoa.
Who's that dude?
That's what it sounds like.
[inaudible]
Jesus Christ.
Dude, listen to these things
for you. Crack them to the roof.
That's just the wind.
That's because they put a camera
on the outside. Go crowd. Yeah,
the wind noises off on those things.
But the sound that it actually makes,
there's one video where it says a
Hellcat challenger where it's just
exhaust. It's so it's, it literally
raises your testosterone. Yeah.
I had this guy in Gad Saad, he's a, uh,
what is his easily some super intelligent,
sophisticated phd type character.
I forget what his degree is in,
but he was talking about, that's
me on it. Sexy as fuck. Fun.
Sexy as fuck. Wow. That has been
photoshopped on the underground,
on mixed martial arts.com
to the point of no return.
Every possible. I can't imagine what
they would do to it. Every foot out,
every possible gay scenario.
That is beautiful.
It's a beautiful car.
How it looks good.
My point is find that a challenger sound,
the sound actually
raises your testosterone,
like literally raises your
testosterone brother in law.
He bought two kind of junked up dot
Shah 73 dodge challengers. And he just,
he's a,
he's a motor head and he put them
together and made this beautiful folks are
[inaudible]
is that growl? Like I'm like,
I'm lying. Sounds so good dude.
[inaudible]
that's an American car that you
can buy and I'm telling you the,
the car when you're driving it,
you're like, this is so nice.
But the inside of it is like comfortable.
It's, it's got like all I'll can Tara,
which is like that artificial
suede everywhere. It feels
good. The dash is great.
It's a fucking incredible car.
It's so,
I'm so happy that they finally started
making like real American muscle cars
again. Cause for the lungs tried
for a while and they were just like,
you guys are fucking missing it.
Yeah. And then like five years ago,
they just went back to the original plans.
That's all we wanted.
Big engine, lots of power, lots
of snacks in the body shape.
They went back to the original.
Ah, that's the only one.
There's one with Eddie Bravo behind me.
These smacking me in the head.
It's hilarious. So
funny. Uh, that's great.
I love those things. Fucking photoshops
or some back in the day, man,
people would get really upset if other
people made fun of him like that.
But I don't, I don't get that. I think
it's funny, like people get mad, like,
do they hate you? They're mad at you.
Like, no, they're not mad at you.
They're making fun. Like, you
can't be made fun of. Does
it change you as a person?
Like you don't think that's funny. Kimbo
slice banging me over the side of a car.
That's hilarious. Yeah. I just had
a, you know, French Stewart? No,
he was from third rock from the sun.
He was the kid. He squinted. Oh,
I saw that show. Anyway, he
was, he was heavily parodied.
He was telling me about like when he was
at his top likes SNL was parroting of
Jimmy Fallon, like, uh, south of ours.
John Lithgow show, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Exception kid and uh,
and south park udo regularly redeem them
for being a horrible actor and all that.
And he's like, he's like, honestly,
I fucking loved it. He goes, it really
made me feel like I had made it.
That's funny. Yeah. Yeah. I'm
American Dad and nailed me once.
No Shit. And I was on fear factor. Yeah.
I pulled up like drinking a beer
in a car and I was looking for
prison.
I pulled up in a car drinking and then,
uh,
I met Seth Macfarlane and I did
his other show. I did, um, um,
Cleveland show? No, the uh, the, the, the,
the, the American debt. No, the other one,
family guy, family guy.
I did family guy. I did,
I played me on family guy like did my
own voice. I'm sure that we got once,
but it funny. He's a nice guy, man.
Seth Mcfarlane's are very friendly,
like Smiley Guy, you know, it was
cool as fuck Judd Apatow. Yeah,
jot appetite was at the
Improv of the night.
He's just hanging out with us
like everybody else. Right.
It was me and him and
Dalea and um, and, and, um,
Jeffrey's Jim Jefferies were
hanging out over by the,
the hallway by where the bathroom is
because there's no fucking green room.
And the Hollywood Improv,
which is the most ridiculous thing ever.
Like Leah was like,
like there's no green room.
Like nobody thinks about the fact
that no green room. I was like, yeah,
if we were in Pittsburgh, we'd
be like, fuck this place. Yeah.
But because it's in town,
we'll just accept the fact that there's
nowhere to stand in between shows.
But Jen hepatologist hanging
out with everybody else.
Yeah.
He came on my podcast one time and then
I went on about six months ago and I
talked about how I thought girls was a
really bad shell and I didn't realize
that he created it. Oh. And then,
and the truth is that only
seen like five minutes.
But I just saw like all I saw is
hipsters and I was like, I fucking,
I hate hipsters.
And so I just immediately judged the show.
I've talked shit about it.
So then somebody of course tweets
out to me and Judd, hey Jed,
how do you feel like Greg Fitzsimmons
saying your show is Eddie said war that
overstated would,
I said like said it's our Shit Ya.
And so then Judd replied to him, that's
a lie. Greg Fitzsimmons is a, you know,
a funny guy and he gets it and he's
a friend and he would never say that.
So then I emailed him
like, dude, I'm so sorry.
I honestly haven't even seen the
shell had even though you created it.
And he gave me like a giant free pass.
And so I went off and I watched it.
And honestly not,
not shitting you.
I watched the first season and
it's actually a really good show.
So you don't like upstairs
I jumped the gun. I can add
stress either, but they're great fodder
there. Great fodder. Yeah. I mean, yeah,
if you were going to do a sitcom and
you didn't have a hipster head today,
you're not thinking straight.
Right?
Hipster would be like one of the
perfect people to fuck with. Yeah.
It's like the Yuppies of the eighties
even better because they take themselves
way seriously and part of their shtick
about being a hipster is you're too cool
for everything. Yeah. Yeah. You're cool
too. Cool. I'm over it. I'm so over this.
I'm so over that.
Not Allowed to get excited about
everything and you have to keep moving on
because if it's not in here,
hipster,
the ultimate hipster who is so crazy,
Nicu Sif,
when he was on the podcast
showed no hipster whatsoever.
He's a normal cool dude
who happens to be a comic.
You need to follow his Twitter because
he has like things. He shows you how to
wash your jeans and like and like
with like toothbrushes and shit.
That doesn't make him a hipster.
How's that make him a hitman?
Sharon bought these jeans where you
don't ever wash them. What? Yeah.
I think those are names through
genes. Genes. We don't ever watch. No.
I swear to God jeans a dirty
bitch. Nope. This a certain type.
They're made of a material that's
supposed to like mold to your body so you
never wash it. Fuck Outta here. That's
ridiculous. It's just someone's fiction.
He talks about in his podcast. Yeah, but
they the person who created those genes,
that's their fiction. Yes. No, it's
close. You fucking dirty bitch.
If you get funky and close,
what are the clothes magically have a
little cleaning robots that run around
inside your Dick. Clean out where
you're farting into your fucking pants.
Levis though. Levi jeans. Oh No, no, no.
See they're saying not to wash your jeans.
That's what I'm saying.
You don't have to wash it.
That's what they're saying.
That you wear it like a jacket.
No,
you don't wash your jacket there so you
don't have to wash your jeans. Yeah,
I sweat. Okay. I sweat all the time.
You're not doing carriage. Get Old.
Steamy my legs, everything. My I,
my body cools itself. Well, yeah,
I get shit done and my jeans
get wet and I'm not wearing wet,
smelly ammonia stinking genes because my,
my sweats gone through them and then
it's dried out and it's got this faint
whiff of funk. Fuck that.
Once I find a pair of pants,
they're going on a lot of trends over,
especially five yogurt
in the morning leave.
I says that you should just freeze
your genes instead of washing.
Oh to kill bacteria. They're
disgusting. They're disgusting.
They not understand that we
have washing machines now.
We're not living in the year fucking
1910 when you had to do that shit with a
rock and a fucking a flat board.
Remember those washboards? Yeah.
Freezer. Yeah. Honey. Why is this?
Turkey tastes like someone's ball.
I do admit I don't wash my jeans
as much as regular clothes though.
I would say I'd say like maybe I'll
wear them like 10 times. That's a lot,
but I'm comfortable with
wearing them for a weekend.
I'll wear the same jeans two days in a
row. No problem. Like if I go on the road,
if I don't feel like packing a lot of
shit, I'll throw in one pair of jeans.
I'll throw on a backup pair just in
case the shit hits the fan because my
fucking bridge troll body
doesn't fit normal jeans.
I have to get specific genes
relate me. Yeah. I can't wear like,
like Levi's five on ones don't.
It's too big. You're your leg.
They won't, that won't go over
past my knees above the knee.
And then it hits the troll part of me.
Yeah.
He tried to sweat pants or the stretchy
jeans that, but that looks too sexy. Let,
I'm trying too hard. Yeah,
because you've got to think.
My ass sticks out a lot in the thighs,
so my dick will be much more smushed
in there. I'd be looking to give up,
trying to get everybody
to at my deck on a set.
I want to see that on the hood of a
charger. But you do, I got into today I'm,
I'm back to the original jeans.
The fucking lightweight
faded does that lady's jeans.
I went back to button. These
are Lucky's. Lucky's fit me.
Lucky's for whatever reason,
lucky jeans, they make them now.
There are more with Louis. Yeah. Lucky's
or Lou. Yeah. More a flight. So Lou,
fuck you don't know.
As long as we
all know, we looked good and once
that's a terrible fucking Photoshop.
Some people's Photoshop skills
are just awful. They're awful.
Everything's out of perspective is
three different people in there.
They use parts from
got to learn how to manipulate images.
Kids that challenging needs to
be your car, Craig for Semans.
We're not getting any younger.
Yeah, I did. Back to that.
If you're not going to
get that and get a Camaro,
they have the new Zl one z 28 there's
two new cars they have standard.
Do you get them to the manual just
like that? That comes with a manual,
but they sound fucking fantastic and
there was a particular sleep and t,
that's another good one. That's the one
she going to get one. I'm getting at.
Although newspapers at $45,000 and it's
fucking 420 horsepower trading that
Prius or the ones that if you got a,
they don't have the 2015 is out yet,
but if you've got a 2014 the
2014 it's a fucking great car.
It's a great car.
It's loud as shit and you could
probably get a really good deal at them.
They have 400 plus horsepower. They
have that coyote engine. It's a,
it's a fucking fire for here.
Is that just gt baseline one a gt?
It's not expensive as far as like
what you get bang for your buck.
You can't do any better than a Mustang
gt. It's a Goddamn fast car. The old cars,
like in the 1970s like when a challenger
came out like the 1970 challenger 1970
71 those cars were ridiculous.
It was 440 horsepower.
No one seen anything like that
with death defying fucking brakes.
The brakes were retarded.
They were awful drum brakes in the rear.
You stomped on the gas, the whole car
went sideways. No traction control,
no nothing.
Just a regular base Mustang
gt will bury that car,
burry it and be able to corner and have
antilock brakes be able to corner and
then they have the other one like
the Laguna Saker Mustang Dude.
It's a great fucking car.
The Lucid Laguna Seca Mustang.
It's like the month they
had a three o two boss,
which is a really good version of the
Mustang as well. It's like for twentyish,
somewhere around horsepower
and it's a great handling car.
Then they took it to the next level
with this Laguna Seca Mustang.
It was like 40 grand,
40 grand,
and it beats an m three around a fucking
race track. It's incredible. I mean it's,
yeah,
it's chintzy inside a little bit.
This is like plastic shit here and
plastic shit there. But seats feel good.
Sounds great. Massive balls,
you know, as far as like a car,
they'll be honest with that. Like,
what are you driving that car for?
You driving that car for the fun of it.
Like that's the fun to hear the rumble
and the engine to feel the acceleration
when you stomp on the gas or shift
your gears, have a good time.
What do you give a fuck what
it looks like? You know,
that's not what this car is about now.
Not about the valet parking.
I'm about the uh,
the four oh five at two in the morning
when it's why I'm come back to the ice
house and it's fucking late going
up Laurel Canyon on the way.
The improv coming over down to Melrose on
pulling up to a red
light and Beverly hills.
And there's some young age and blame the
next car and you eyeball them and with
that was you have to be,
see,
why can't it be a black guy? Let's go
weird. Pull up that Laguna Seca Mustang
that I don't think there Megan is anymore.
It's a,
you're probably still find some of them
that are on lots that they haven't sold
yet because what about the,
oh, that's ridiculous. Car.
I had one of those gt 500 convertible.
The problem with the convertible doors
or feels like you could die. Yeah.
Any moment. There's nothing above your
hand. Look at that car. Oh, the car is,
I believe somewhere around 420 horsepower
and unbelievably fast around Natural
Laguna. Yeah, it's like 40 grand and
those wheels is standard with it. Yeah.
That's what it looks like. Yeah. It's a
fun and Gar man. He could be a man again.
You could be a man again, Gregory. I
remember what it was like. I had hair,
but it's fun. You don't need the
hair. No, it's not coming back.
You don't need the hair shaved.
The rest of it be a light bulb.
But be a light bulb and a
fucking fun con and joy. Yeah.
Maybe you can take to wearing crazy
sunglasses like Elton John did.
Or maybe I wear the wigs like
a Phil Spector, Phil Spector.
Imagine if we started doing that.
You and I just started wearing wigs and
all of our shows and never addressing,
never address it. No, no jokes
about it. And people ask questions.
You Act like what you're
saying is everywhere you go,
it's like everyday it's different.
Not only that,
sometimes we wear bald caps with hair on
the side of the size of the class. Yeah.
Mohawks. One day. Sometimes it's
an Afro. Yeah. Never bring it up.
Trade and trade them out with each other.
Sometimes it's like Farrah Fawcett,
like Farrah Fawcett in the 70s you got
like little curls and shit. Yeah. Yeah.
Mullets mullets all kinds of weeks.
Just never work for guys.
I used to date a chick
who had a shaved head.
She shaved her head so long time ago.
It was like early nineties she
shaved her head and wore wigs.
She's from another country. She's a
singer. She was just very eccentric. Yeah.
But she,
uh,
she would fucking rock a different wig
and like sometimes she would like show up
at the comedy store and I wouldn't even
know it was her, you know, I was like, oh,
hey,
this is when I had first moved to La.
So I didn't really know how
wacky people got. Hmm. You know,
I hadn't been around that many wacky
folks. This chick was, uh, you know,
someone who came to Hollywood with the
sincere purpose of becoming even wackier,
you know, famous. Yeah.
It didn't work out,
but just talented check but crazy.
Yeah. She wore wigs. There's though,
yeah,
Eddie Bravo
spanking me.
I can't tell him he's hitting me in the
head or that you would like Bruce Willis.
I think he's getting both the
ass in the head. Crack, crack,
crack the u g that's the underground.
Um,
when people wore wigs,
I mean cars,
when you think about like the
divorce belt comics, you know,
like Freddy Roman and these guys,
they slapped that little glue,
slap that shit on,
head to the Gig through on the Tuxedo,
put on a nice edge piece. And then during
the day, nothing. They're working out.
Bald headed then work out
now? No, at the fryer.
Some of these guys worked out because
they had heart attacks and they, yeah,
they had like a,
they had a stair master.
I think you've had an
ashtray on the side of it,
but you're talking about like
late in their life. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Well I'm talking about like when
they were like touring the Catskills,
there was no working out,
but then were wigs were wigs,
lem glow around the top
runner run the pay line.
Then how did you want a pain in the ass?
That would be,
could you see the photos of Mickey Rourke
with a wig now? Oh my God. So hilarious.
Like you were Rourke.
Where's a hairpiece now and it's the
most ridiculous hairpiece of all time.
And he was wearing in New York and
they got these photos of him. It's,
it's so crazy. It's almost like easily is
he being silly? Like, cause he trolling.
But then you see him when he was
on like the Jimmy Kimmel show,
he had the hairpiece like quaffed and it
looked pretty good. But it's, it's crazy.
He's like, he's like 60 something years
old. Just like shave your fucking head.
It would be funny like to do a one
hour special. This look at his head.
Oh dear God, dear God. And this
is like a shower cap. Yeah.
And this is not even the worst photo.
There's this even worse
photos of it dreaded.
It doesn't make any cause
it's coming out of nowhere.
It's a wig and it doesn't match
the hair that's underneath.
Well it's always the
side here by their ears.
When you see like little like land
flimsy side here by their ear.
But then the top is this fucking lush
Maine. It doesn't make any sense.
Like think for my next one hour special,
I'm going to shave my head and get a
silly wig and just wear it. Why not?
Why not? How about um, like a big red one,
like a big carrot top style. What
does that, is that a different wig?
That's a different one.
Who's got to keep having fun?
Look at the guy on the right hand corner.
He's jealous. Smells like dead wig.
The WIG is beautiful. Mickey. Let me
tell you, making God is my witness.
That wig looks so real.
That is so realistic.
No one knows if they tell you
they know that fucking assholes.
Did you good at Irvy in the Bronx?
Where did you get that piece? My piece.
I looked like there's a skunk
asleep on my head. But this,
there's other ones of the gray one.
That's the Brown one. He's got a gray one.
The gray, the gray ones. The most
ridiculous cause it's like, wait a minute.
What's going on here? How did you get
all that gray hair? Look at it. There's,
that's a good one. Oh, it's so crazy.
Plus he to work on his face. Right?
It's far ahead. Got Pumped up.
Maybe it looks better now than it
looked in the past. Quite honestly.
He used to have chin or cheek
implants. Yeah, and when the fighter,
you really saw it. Oh yeah. Yeah.
His face was kind of funds
that the movie with a,
when he was a professional wrestler,
like past his prime. Oh, the wrestler,
the wrestler. The fighter was the
market mark, right? Yeah. But that, uh,
he actually, his face looks at
least like a normal older guy. Now,
there was one point in time where you
had these crazy cheek implants put in his
face. His whole face was just puffy.
It looked like he got stung by bees.
So see if you can find those pictures.
Mickey Rourke cheek implants.
How many people watch this as
they're listening to the podcast?
Less weight. Less like, it's
90% of them just listen.
But a lot of times folks have like,
we'll say something like this,
they'll write it down, let
go, and then they'll like,
text me or tweet me or something
later. Like, what the fuck?
I just saw Mickey Royce hair takes
a lot. Dick, now I can sleep.
But the like I hear you guys talking
about and I had a look but he um,
it's like,
uh,
that's something that happens to a
lot of those people that are like,
they're sort of like separated
from rational thinking.
They get this body dysmorphia
thing going on, you know,
there's been pictures of them like there
is like that's post a face stretching,
but there's ones like the one
that you just crossed over Brian,
the one with the red shirt. Little lower
than that. That's yeah, right there.
That looks like he's got the
cheek implants in place. Cat.
Good look any west.
Who when he was young even remember that?
What was the pope of
Greenwich Village Diner.
That's like nine and a half weeks
ago. Yeah. Oh Man. Yeah. You can't,
but like that thing that happens when
you pull your face back like that,
you can't do that. Like that's
not better. It's not better.
That's knows you did it. You looked
like a burn victim. You look weird,
you're shiny,
your face all stretched out and it
shows that you care way too much.
Like it's not getting better. It's
just getting different. It's screen.
It's like you're screaming. I can't
handle that. I'm getting older.
I'm panicking like there's some shit
that you could do that actually does make
you look better.
Like I guess if you have a ridiculous
knows and you get that bitch trimmed down,
you're happy with a good for you,
but that's a slippery slope man.
You don't see big noses like
he used to. Very rare. Nope.
Nobody keeps a managed [inaudible] gals.
A lot of 17th birthday presence.
She, I was in high school.
Girl did it turned,
changed her fucking look so radically,
but she kind of over did it. I'm
like, she had a, she had this, she,
the poor girl was a beautiful girl with
a crazy knows and she got a crazy knows,
trimmed down and she looked beautiful,
but the nose had liked that ski slope
thing going on and that little smashed
front, there's a little bit of
a flat part in the middle of it.
They went too hard,
like they needed to just leave
on just like a millimeter more,
be a little bit big, a little bit
just yeah, it matched her face better,
but it was like obvious
that something's going on.
Like if you're looking at her face,
you couldn't help but notice that
something went on with her nose. Yeah.
And then a lot of times those days those
things collapse like they don't and
they have to build them back up.
And when they do that,
then you can run into complications.
Sometimes they have to use a piece of
your cartilage from your ribs to recreate
the cartilage inside your nose.
God,
I wonder how many no's Jab
that you could find out.
There's gotta be a number of nose jobs
that are performed every year and you
could figure out what percentage of the
population that's Bruce Jenner before he
became a woman though he's different
now. He grew up in my town, Bruce Jenner.
Terry got long nails
now and long manicure.
There was some talk about him being
preop that he might go for it.
It looks like he's going for it. If I had
to get, I mean, I don't like to gossip.
Yes,
I do.
I don't like to gossip too much about
someone that looks like they're troubled,
but he looks like he's troubled. It
doesn't look like he's going for a look.
It looks like something's going on,
like what's going on and he's
living with the Kardashians.
That's obviously terrible for
you. Yeah, that's gotta be toxic.
I'd rather live in Chernobyl than live
in that house and tried to keep my sanity
with cameras on. So you can't
even be bitchy to them. Yeah.
I think if I lived in Chernobyl,
I could wear some sort of
suit that would protect me.
That's not a suit that protects you
from dopes. Like if sharing the house,
those dummies,
your skin would look better too if
you lived in Chernobyl in his does,
but not only that, the strategy of
just constantly seeking attention,
like there's like, okay, that's
weird. Wow, that's weird.
That's Photoshop. Nope, no, no.
That's not just a guy who's kind of
out of shape who's older. No, that's,
that's weird.
And there's another one recently with
it shows his nails like it shows like he
has long nails all sudden no matter how.
No matter what you started with,
once you've gotten the third facial
surgery, it all ends at Michael Jackson.
It can. He looks like Michael
Jackson in that picture. Well,
body dysmorphia is real shit man.
You know it's real shit.
Like there's his nails that long though.
Minds about that long.
So they're not please, unless
you're a pain. I've seen
the longer than that. Yeah.
Either way. The guy looks like he's
troubled. There is a guy, you know,
you think about famous people
that are kind of enigma is like,
he didn't do anything except the
76 Olympics. He won the decathlon.
He is a, you know, before the Kardashians,
people in America knew Bruce Jenner.
The only thing you did was a Wheaties
box and the decathlon. That's crazy.
That was fucking 40 years
ago. It is crazy. Yeah.
That's real when you put it
that way. Yeah, you're right.
And then you've got people
that like John Larroquette,
he could walk into a fucking mall and
nobody would know who the dude was. True.
But the only reason why he still like
the only reason why he's still famous is
because of the Kardashians, but
it's fact. But prior to that,
he was in the national consciousness.
People who knew who Bruce Jenner was,
he as a, maybe as a
subject, maybe as a name,
but not as someone you recognize. Yeah.
I don't think you would recognize him.
I think his resurgence is entirely
based on living with all these attention
whores. Yep. That's what it's all about.
the 70s had those kinds of stars
that yet evil Knievel who, you know,
there had never been a stunt man
before. That's true. He was the first,
he was like, you know what, Bob Marley is
to reggae? Like he's the only reggae guy.
Anybody ever gave a fuck about
or ever will Jimmy cliff. Yeah.
He was in the band though. That's
true. But basically, you know,
you've got jackass and all
those guys, so that, that's,
that's the first time there's been
stunted people since. Right. Um,
and then you had, um, you know,
certain comics that were famous from the
70s that were just weird. Like, uh, uh,
what's the name? Tip Toe through the tiny,
Tim was famous as shit. Still famous.
People still know who tiny Tim is.
True. But that was Letterman, right?
Was it think so. Yeah. I think
on the Letterman show, I think
they got married on the Letterman show.
Didn't I like in Vegas, him and uh,
whatever her name was.
Miss Miss something. Whoa.
Yeah. Hmm. Yeah. Interesting man.
It's weird how fame you can't predict
who's going to last with fame.
Um, you know, like of
the Charlie's angels,
you didn't know Farah was going to,
I guess he kind of knew Pharaoh
was going to be the one,
but you thought the other ones would
be pretty big to Jaclyn Smith. I mean,
all she did was hair shampoo
commercials for the rest of her life.
She was honest.
Fuck hot as fuck my,
my kid is watching Charlie's angels reruns
right now. I've watched one yesterday.
Try pulling yourself away. Oh, I could
stare at those chicks all fucking day.
It's also weird that you're [inaudible].
It's Kinda like when you watch a show like
that, it's not just that, oh you know,
Jaclyn smiths pretty, but it's also
like this is a time capsule. This is,
they've captured this stuff that went
on in the 1970s and you watch it again.
All right. That's weird man.
That's a weird, and their outfits,
I mean talked about the bootleg jeans,
they were aware and the seven,
eight encapsulated seventies
fashion. Yeah, no shit man. You know,
like a denim denim vests in the feathered
hair and they probably fall in a big
part. We're one of the reasons
why I became so popular.
Right. Why the fashion did,
yeah. I'm sure on those shows, I'm sure.
Like I guarantee you the dukes of hazard
probably influenced a lot of idiots to
wear cowboy boots. Daisy Dukes,
definitely daisy daisy. Yeah.
Launched that dude. She might've been
the hottest chick ever on TV. Yeah. Yeah.
See Right. Who Chrissy from? From
fucking three's company. Daisy Duke. No.
How dare you take Chrissy cause
you're broken. You're incisor broaden.
You have to go to a doctor to keep telling
you. Go to a doctor, Chris, he's hot,
but she's not as hot as daisy dukes.
You know it was pretty
hot even though she's,
but she's older so you can't compare it
to go from an old pick of Catherine Bach.
Fuck, I know what you're going to do,
but I'm the chick from modern family,
the old Latino woman or
dude, I'll take it. Yeah,
she's only 40 I mean, but she looks like
she's 30 and her tits still look like,
I don't know. You can't fake it. They
have there just some of that cleavage.
You can push it up, but she doesn't
push it up where it's straining.
It's a little bit of bounce,
a little bit about little jiggle,
but yet there's the, there's Pie.
Their pie shaped perfectly round.
She's stupid hot hand and that
accent puts it right over the top.
She's stupid hot and there's this element
of knowing that this is not going to
last like what you are as you're looking
at a flower that's been cut and you're
putting it in the vase and it's just
like something even extra beautiful about
the fact that it's not even
attached to the root anymore.
You've got a day to look at it like this.
This is it.
Tomorrow's going to be wilted the day
after that you're gonna want to throw it
out. But right now he's the hunter
Thomas of hot. Yeah. Yeah. Thompson.
What did I say? Thomas? Jesus Christ.
Okay. You know both of them are hot.
Yeah, but daisy Dukes, dirtier curse.
He's bending over like fuck me in the
ass hole. I'll tell you what, like,
who's done a better job of keeping
it together? Well, both of them,
both of them failed. Oh,
she did the exercise videos.
She can type for a little
tight for a little bit.
Still doing that shampoo commercials.
That's not Jaclyn Smith though.
That's daisy Duke. That's Catholic. Um,
nobody worked at Ferris Nipples
were permanently erect on that show.
You're probably, I used them up before
every scene. I bet they did. Right?
They take,
these guys would get like pumped up.
Guys would do like pushups and stop before
scenes to pump up their muscles. Yeah,
I guarantee you they did
that. They went for it. Yeah.
That was everything and that was what
you were selling. If you're selling it,
you're selling cars where you leave
them dirty or what'd you Polish them?
He got a polish the car. You got to
polish the car. You're selling cars,
you're selling tickets. What are you
doing? Get that ice cube out, honey. Yeah,
I'm on the headlights now. We sell the
story. Nobody's watching it for the story.
That's a, when she died, man, that was
one of those things where it's like, wow,
wow,
Farrah faucets dead.
That was just hard to wrap my head around
because when I was a kid, she was aunt.
It was it. Everybody had a Farrah
Fawcett poster on their wall.
Every girl did and it was that one poster
of her like smiling and she had the
feathered hair and everything like that.
Like she influenced a whole
generation of where that here,
it's gotta be the quintessential
poster in American of all time.
Probably most famous posters ever.
Yeah. Yeah. That's it right there.
Look at her on rail and the nipple.
You can't see that's not high def.
So you can't see the nipple,
but the nipple is very proudly display it.
And this semester,
yeah,
many of the photos of the nipple
rock and she was so pretty. Yeah.
She was like one of the first
television bombshell types, right?
Uh, yeah. I mean my favorite was,
you know what, I take it back.
My favorite was wonder woman. Old
Wonder woman. Oh, Linda Carter.
Lynda Carter's. Tough to look
at now. Yeah. Not that she
looks at Lynda Carter was,
there you go. There it is. Oh
Shit. Look at that. Nibble.
Yeah. Linda Carter. I mean
she doesn't look terrible,
but she's an older woman now.
It's just when you remember how beautiful
she was when she was wonder woman,
I wish they would die.
I don't want to say it ruins it.
You know what's fucked though, man? Like,
it's weird when you go back and watch
like Batman or any of those old school
like superheroes. No one
worked out. No one worked out.
A lot of belly. You look at Catherine
Bach there. She didn't work out.
Look at her legs.
Felt like all mushy and shit.
Everybody was all mushy and sloppy.
They were good for a couple of decades.
John Wayne,
whoa.
Beer belly and shit
with little skinny arms
to get the badge for the gap. Look at
the legs, the size of her thighs. Dude,
her fucking body. That is, she was an
athlete. She was in an Olympic athlete,
I believe. Oh my God, she's hot.
Let's all agree. She's the hottest
she is. Yeah, I think she is not.
It was the hottest. Oh, wait a minute.
We're forgetting a major contender.
Who? Barbara Eden. I dream of Jeannie.
She wins. She wins. She wins. Yeah.
She wins one and she's subservient.
She'll we want it was
beautiful. Yeah. Yeah.
There's a comic on long island that fucked
her. Yeah. Yeah. Late in life though,
right? They didn't lie, but he can
say he did it. She was still hot.
It doesn't matter how old she
was, but she would like, you know,
fucking find a guy, pick them out and
going, come on, let's do this. Yeah.
Well she knew she could, you know,
she was got damn Barbara Eden.
I know somebody who had said late in life,
I should say. Allegedly. Yeah. Well this,
I know somebody who allegedly had no,
I know that we definitely had sex.
I'll very late in life.
Real a hospital bed. Like
actually I'll say winter
woman. I don't think I like,
that's a horrible pose. Yeah,
that's fun. It's fun. Another one because
wonder woman, you can find a bad one too,
I'm sure. But you found a good one.
Uh, you know, also turned me on,
but she wasn't like a few years
before she died. Whoa. Uh,
who was not bombshell
hot but stole my heart.
Was Valerie Bertinelli one day
to talk to you anymore? Yeah.
You become a different person
to me. You know, Shit. No,
I don't trust your judge
like that. I mean, cause you
did a moment ago. Now Mike,
Greg's drunk. All right,
look at that fella.
She married Eddie van Halen. How bad could
you be there? I knew about a backside.
It's like ill, no wonder
woman even work out, man.
They didn't work out back then.
There's gotta be a better
picture of her wonder woman.
I'm sure it had a little bit of, I
don't mind. A little bit of body fat.
I think it's hot. Yeah. I like women
to have like a little softness to them.
I love Kim Kardashian.
I mean I don't like her person or soul,
but I love that body.
Her body is fantastic.
Within the harass is fat or
real or as real fat, whatever.
It is ridiculous.
Like if you don't get excited about that,
your Dick stop working right now. You're,
you're a, you're a closeted homosexual.
If that's not working for
you. Dick's just sad. Yeah.
Dick doesn't want full pleasure,
Dixon. No, I'm just wanting to,
skinny girl cuts me with her hips.
Like a guy who buys a Prius when
he wants a Mustang, a Mustang,
or get this challenger. Now,
if I'm going to do what?
It's going to be the Mustang because
I had a fetish for mustangs as a kid.
I still do. I think I need the fact
that it's the 40th anniversary.
It's Kinda 50th anniversary.
It's pretty cool. Well,
the new one's going to have independent
rear suspension was going to make a big
difference in the way it handles the
2015 yeah, there'll be out pretty soon.
I think they're out in the fall, which
is, you know, basically right here. God,
she was so hot. Whoa. Oh, she
was so hot as ridiculous. Yeah.
Linda Carter might've been
the hottest woman of all time.
She might when she might win. Yeah.
Oh, bitch was hot. Oh, wait a minute.
What's that look is that
she went from modern family.
Oh God. She wins. She
wins. She wins. Everybody
wins.
There's women that are listening to this
right now. Look, fuck you. Yeah. Well,
let's talk about,
we talked about Jim Morrison being hot.
We talked about Joey Lawrence
being hot. Yeah, he was beautiful.
We did a lot for the ladies
on that. Especially since
we don't feel it. You know,
we assume that he's hot, you know, I mean,
I see how you would be attracted to him.
No, no, I totally felt your
energy when he came on.
So I understood that he was hot zone.
The star Doon Doon Doon Doon
what about Janet Jackson?
Early nineties? No, I playboy cover of
black and white. It's never into that. Oh,
I always found it to be so like
needy. A racial, I need a race.
Pick a race. Well, I just,
I just want someone who's like a pop
superstars when they're forcing them down
your throat. They never seem sexy
to me. It always seemed like, oh,
here's this crazy person.
Right? What's her name? Um,
uh, Miley Cyrus. It's like, oh, they
want you to think she's hot now,
but you know,
was pretty spears was a child star and
they forced her out and she was fucking
hot.
But she was hot in a way that like,
like if I saw a bunch of peacocks and
there was a female peacock that was an
exceptional specimen, I was like, wow,
that's a beautiful peacock is like that.
It's like to me hot. I mean
I, yes, physically. Yeah.
Undeniable shape and all that very
beautiful button, right? No animals.
Things pulling me towards
that. Everything's pushing
me away from that. Yeah.
That she's danced madness.
It's craziness.
Like that has to be part of the picture.
It has to be who's the person?
Like can you interact with the person?
It can't just be the way they look.
The way they look is great. I mean
it's important. It's something,
it gives you a charge,
but if you know that their personality is
all out of whack, like you're like, Ugh,
it's just to note, I want,
I'm a little out of whack.
The thing that attracted me as a,
as an insecure guy when I
was single was a woman I got,
I saw the end,
I saw the dead dad left or you know,
she's got, she's got like
a unit brow. You find.
I would find that one thing
and I'd be like, I got a shot.
That would make me so much more attracted.
If a girl was perfect,
I felt nothing and it wasn't even that.
I didn't think I could get her.
It just made me feel like too much work.
Well also like somebody who's a
little fucked up, they're gonna,
you're gonna fucking connect with them.
There's going to be up charge between
cause you both need something bad to
complete yourself. That's a good point.
Yeah. I definitely felt that way.
Like girls had Rick really good
relationships with their family. Like, oh,
I know girls. Like uh, you know, they want
you to go hang out with their parents.
Right. And like, Oh yeah. Not really.
No. Especially if you couldn't relate.
I want a girl who needs help finding her
father that Nicki Minaj is new video.
Do you see that one?
That fucking Jamie keeps going on and
on about it won't stop talking about it.
It's so much.
But yeah,
and it's like there's parts where she's
fingering herself in a video and a good
kid. I love that my kids see this shit,
which is low. Her ass is ridiculous. Yeah,
they're all ass. Everybody's got asked. If
you look at, if you look at Miley Cyrus,
his Twitter avatar that she's,
she put her own version of her album
cover on it and it looks like she has a
great ass too.
Well that's an illusion.
They're Photoshop the shit out
of that girl weighs 18 pounds.
Just a little stick figure. Yeah,
she's a very boy. Like with her body.
Like when that thing came out in the
video music awards and she danced around
and rubbed up against that guy.
You could see like she's very
like [inaudible] or skinny.
She's like skinny girl Nikki mouth.
She's athletic. It's not supple. Yes.
That girl,
just a fuck house.
You'll look at her and you're like,
whoa.
I mean that's just fucking,
just come. That's just,
cause he's backed up like a camel. All
the loads of his shot and in the world.
Yeah.
Calm.
She's all sex cocked with com. Yeah.
Like some girls like they have to,
you know, they have to do something to
look sexy. When a girl is built like that,
it's like Jesus. And then on top of
that she's doing all the sexy shit.
Sticking her ass up in the Jennifer
Lopez was like that in her prime.
Isn't it amazing though when we're talking
about like John Wayne and Batman and
all that shit. The difference
between how the women are portrayed,
the difference between how singers
are portrayed, the the music videos,
the photographs,
all that stuff and then go back and
think about like Carly Simon. Yeah.
There was none.
The Carole king and Janis Joplin.
I mean Janice shopping wasn't the
most attractive woman in the world,
but she was funny man. She
liked, didn't like women.
Like there was an interview
with Janis Joplin. Is that her?
Miley Cyrus is Miley Cyrus's
version of this. Listen, listen man,
that's fish a shout. That's not her
ass. Yeah, that shit ain't real.
That is real. No, Nicki Minaj
is real, but that's not real.
That's obviously same ass.
Yeah, it's exactly the same.
That said Photoshop. Yeah,
look, exactly. See the crease on the
top of the thigh is exactly the same.
The top left thigh. Don't ever go to that
other one again. This is like a cartoon.
You show me a cartoon.
What were we talking about?
We're talking about her ass.
About how for some women they almost,
it's like they've extracted the blueprint
in the DNA of men of what makes us
orgasm and they have just
projected it on a body. No,
what I was saying was that you never saw
this from artists in like the seventh.
Right. You never saw this from women
that were like super attractive.
Like you know, like Linda
Ronstadt, you know, beautiful,
beautiful woman. You know,
when she was young and in her prime,
you'll never saw her in underwear. Nikki,
uh, um, Fleetwood Mac. Oh,
Stevie nicks. She was big.
She was always like, she was like the
chick from heart got hired. His big,
didn't she get big?
I think she got big,
but not when they were in there playing
when she was young and Jelic but she was
wearing flowing shit.
She was never showing her body.
Was a woman from heart big in the
beginning or did she get she and Wilson?
She started small and then she got bigger.
There's Anne and Nancy Wilson.
One of them married, uh,
uh, the famous director.
The guy who did a dazed and confused.
Who's that? I don't remember that.
That's the, the the blond one. Who's
the blonde one?
Yeah.
Yeah, but she, uh, Ann Wilson could
sing or fucking hell. Yeah. Right.
Carnie Wilson was a different one. Those
Wilson Phillips does different animal.
Totally different animals. She got big
tits. She looked like a carny. Yeah.
There was like Carney had like,
her sister was like super skinny and
she was like really big and it was like
baffling.
Didn't she do like a talk show for awhile?
Well, I think she was, wasn't she? The
daughter of the Mamas and the Papas?
Yes. Can't be a good time. No.
Can't be a good guy growing up in
that fucking crazy household now.
But I'm that fucking Ann
Wilson from heart. Yeah.
What a voice. She lost all that weight.
Good for her. That's what happened. Right.
She lost all the weight and then she
did a talk show or something like that.
Does that Nancy or an does the
big one? That Carney. Okay.
Yeah. Good for her. Did she have to get
like stomach thing? Yeah, I think so.
That's a, it's a weird
thing man. You know. Um,
I was talking to a friend who had
that done. She had it done like, uh,
20 years ago and she was saying that,
um,
it's not just that like that does
make you lose weight. She goes,
but to keep it off,
like you got to go to counseling,
like whatever it is that made you overeat
like that, you've got to address that.
You got to get on top of that.
No, I know a guy who's been
drinking hard his whole life,
he just went to get a shot to stop
drinking. It's like, you know,
that may make you averse to alcohol.
Your body is going to
go find something else.
You've got to deal with why you're
drinking. Oh, shot to stop drinking. Yeah.
I didn't even know the hand that,
what does it do and I didn't,
all I know is he said he was going
to his appointment to get it famous.
A famous guy, she's like, peppermints not,
I should start saying these famous
names should start or shouldn't.
You should start saying eh,
unless they be you.
Would you want anybody saying that your
story in this case? No, probably right.
I'm the opposite of a name dropper.
That's a sad thing man. It's a same thing.
That fucking monster that eats at your
soul that you can't let go the killing
you and the longer you do it,
the harder it gets because the more
you think that it's really part of you,
you know and quitting something. I can
tell you firsthand. It's the most freeing,
empowering thing in the world because you
think this thing that was sapping your
energy that you believe was
built in your foundation,
you get freed of it and you all a sudden
like you take a giant chunk of low self
esteem and just lop it off.
Yeah.
I've met a month a bunch of dudes that
used to be junkies and now or like super
hyper athletes, like a lot of, a lot of
competitive guys like in the UFC. Even,
there's a few guys in the UFC that were
junkies and then they became like Matt
Brown,
one of the top welterweight contender
is part of his whole story is he died.
He had an overdose and fucking
died and came back from it. Yeah.
Does she five dumb and now he's a monster.
Destroys people.
He's like one of the
top guys in the world.
Alice Cooper's like a pro golfer
now is he? He plays that good. Yeah.
Wow.
He doesn't live in Arizona.
Arizona plays at the Biltmore Hotel
in Phoenix. There's a famous course,
their replays. That's hilarious. What
does he do with his time? Just plays golf.
I did a benefit there
with, uh, with uh, um, uh,
Gary Valentine and uh,
he came out and he played
school's out for summer and 18.
All his hits songs with the full makeup
on the whole thing in this fucking for a
fridge charity for like 200 people
did it full on and gave 100%.
Wow. And then hung out and talk to people
afterwards and then played in the golf
tournament all weekend. Took
his makeup though. Yeah,
he's a, he's like a conservative.
Yes. Isn't that interesting?
I don't think he could live in that
part of the world if you weren't.
You can't Scottsdale like
that. Phoenix, Scottsdale.
That's hardcore cocaine and conservatism.
Sheriff Joe. Yeah, that's Gerald piles.
Yeah.
That's like fear of Mexicans and then
cocaine all mixed up together and
sunscreen.
So you get the cocaine from the Mexican
and then you get afraid of him and then
you get sunscreen just fucking seeping
those chemicals into your skin and some
sort of a weird way they need to take
a Xanax lay by the pool Wackos fucking
balls around the grass.
That should not be there by the way.
Especially in a place that has a
massive drought. Right, right. Massive.
No fucking water.
And you're talking about a three square
mile piece of real estate and it just,
so that, so that a hundred chief all
can entertain themselves for four hours.
Yeah.
When people go like why does it golf
course cross $250 million a year run if it
does. Yeah. I mean not that much,
but like if you get a membership
and a prime country club,
like you have to pay like
$100,000 $200,000 for some
of those places they don't
want in any riff Raff, they want to
make sure that you get some money.
And what they do is it's a right,
the reason they can afford it is because
they call it undeveloped parkland.
And so the environmental standards call
for them in every city and so they're
able to get a full write off because
they call it basically like wild land.
He,
while they're seeming fertilizer and
chemicals into the ground water every day,
I can't believe that's all they
call it. Undeveloped Parkland, man.
It's just white people paradise.
That's all it is. Yeah.
And when they buy these big memberships,
they, yeah, there's like a bond and yeah,
there's like half a million.
Donald Trump's got courses where I
bet you it's like $1 million a minute,
some bond,
but you're splitting ownership of the
club with the other maybe 200 members.
So maybe it's not a million,
half a million,
but then you can sell that bond when you
leave and it could be worth more money.
That's hilarious.
But it keeps the club from ever
being sold because think about it.
Riviera country club in fucking Brentwood.
Do you know how much money you would
make in condos if you put condos on that
land and instead you got a hundred
white guys playing golf there one day.
Do the math on that. Yeah, no shit. Right.
This is one place that
I was in the history
channel office was talking to them about
a show and I was looking out the window
at this country clubs. It must be Beverly
hills. Beverly Hills Country Club. Yeah.
I don't know. There's a, there's a,
there's like two on the
west side that are prima.
It's the most ridiculous thing ever.
Cause you're looking at hundreds of
acres in the prime of Beverly Hills.
When you looking out this window and
you're like, how much is that worth?
Like that spot right out
there might be worth billions.
It might be worth a couple billion
dollars. Think about it. One Green is,
you know, 5,000 square feet.
That's enough to put a house.
You know what the land on the land with
a tear down a house in Beverly Hills is
one point $5 million.
Times that by a green,
there's baby, that amount of
space for 20 of those on a whole,
that's 20 million a hall a
whole times 18 holes. Oh my God.
That's like a half a billion dollars.
Oh my God. And it's right there.
It's right there. And it's using up
insane amounts of water. There was a,
I think it was a vice article.
What? I don't know who put it up,
but it was about like, if we really
are taking this drought seriously,
we need to band golf courses. Like
everyone's saying, don't wash your car.
Fuck you.
How about golf courses?
Like let's look at what a golf courses
like what you're talking about is insane.
You're using up more. There
was some fucking statistic
like the, I'll pull it up.
Um, uh, band golf calls of
course, as I better come. So the,
there's some statistic about what the
amount of just in California alone,
California and Florida are like the number
one spots for golf courses in Arizona,
Arizona right there too. But um, it's,
it's an incredible, China has
a golf course van. I saw a,
an article about how many of those courses
because they overexpanded when guy,
when tiger woods came along,
golf got so big they were building
courses everywhere and then when he got
caught with the waffle house waitress,
it all went away.
And there are hundreds of courses around
the country and they just showed photos,
weeds,
chest high weeds growing all over the
entire course to just abandoned. Wow.
This is the,
it is a vice article and it said instead
of killing lawns we should be banning
golf. Cause it's telling people
not to water their lawn. Yeah.
This is what they're saying.
This is,
this is the statistics cause
it's pretty fucking crazy.
The average golf course uses
312,000 gallons of water.
How often? A day doesn't say
hold on family for, okay.
The average American family of four use.
Oh per day. Ready for this? Yeah, per day.
The average American family of four
uses 400 gallons of water a day.
The average golf course uses 300
to 312,000 gallons of water a day.
Okay.
So each golf course uses as much water
as 780 families of four in palm springs
immediately adjacent to a
place called the palm desert.
That NPR reported that each of the cities,
57 courses uses about a
million gallons a day,
a million gallons a day.
Can you go back to the numbers of
people that are actually using it? Yeah,
it's insane. It's, it's my newt.
So it's the same amount of
water as 2,500 families of,
for every one in palm springs
because palm springs is not a spring.
It's fucking desert.
It's got to get the water from
California or from the Colorado River.
We steal it from them. And that's the
reason why that whole salt and sea exists.
You know, the Salton Sea, which is this
gigantic inland sea that is in, um,
the, the areas near the palm desert. Why
is it a c? Well, that's what's crazy.
It was a c because they flooded the area
with the Colorado River back in like
the 50s or some shit like
that a long time ago.
And there's a bunch of great documentaries
on the salt and sea because it's
totally polluted now.
It's polluted with farm runoff and it
became like super salty and people still
pull fish out of it and eat it.
And people still live there.
But it was at one point in time they
used to call it the inland Riviera,
like it was beautiful.
Like pull up the salt and sea,
the inland Riviera, like
some videos, Nevada. No, no,
it's California dude. It's, it's a
huge inland sea. It's enormous. Wow.
And if you saw it, you'd be
like, what the fuck is this?
All that farm country up there.
So it's all just draining all coming down
to palm springs and it's so fucked up
that there's beaches on the
salt and sea that are all bones.
It's not sand, it's fish bones
where they have these die offs.
These fish die offs of like a
million fish will die off. I mean,
this is what it looks like now, but
look at it. This is the salt and say,
this is an inland lake. They created
that huge, let it play a little bit
like this or this.
I liked the music.
It's called the Salton Sea.
It's the largest body of
water in California and
it's not even supposed to be
there
at the turn of the last century.
And engineering's grew
up of epic proportions,
diverted the Colorado River
into one of the lowest,
hottest planned basins in United States.
It took two years to stem the tide,
and when the flooding finally stopped,
350 square miles of desert lay underwater,
everyone assumed that giant inland sea
that had created by accident would just
dry up.
But when it didn't,
real estate developers tried to turn an
ecological disaster into an opportunity.
[inaudible] new.
I'm glad for the crowd with
millions and big cities. Uh,
palm springs with water areas.
Guys back then,
he's in a boat and he's got a suit and
tie on and Riviera beside the booze.
All of them to say as the place for
you to take charge of your future,
you can come as you are. They call it
the fish. Enjoy life at the Riviera
[inaudible]
for a while,
it really did seem like a miracle.
Tourists flock to a place that
had once been unforgiving desert.
People bought homes, built
schools, restaurants, clubs,
but then the sea turned on them.
Over the years,
it's water fed only by agricultural
runoff became saltier than the ocean.
Botulism poisoning killed millions
of fish in a massive die offs.
During the height of 120 degrees,
summers made the air almost unbeatable.
Wow. Began to flood
unpredictably. Tourist sled
boomtown's turned into ghost towns.
Millions of dead fish.
Do you imagine the smell out of
science fiction? Unbelievable.
In the streets.
Every one of the named still waiting
for neighborhoods that never arrived.
Beaches made not of shell or sand,
but of the polarized skeletons
of uncountable millions of fish
houses have tumbled
into toxic looking pits.
It's apocalyptic.
Where's the Riviera? I go there to catch
glimpses of what the world really is.
Yeah. This is what our
country is going to look like.
Greg's going dark on us.
Yeah.
I just read an article about it today.
They're predicting in
the next hundred years.
This is a rustic galactic drought
coming. Well, it really, yeah.
This drought that's in California is so
bad that they're saying that can trigger
earthquakes and so, oh no shit. Yeah.
Drown can trigger earthquakes. Checks out,
so sell.
If California's drought weren't scary,
I know now it may trigger
earthquake scientists believe.
Well the drought is spooky. It's been
three years. Last year it rained once.
No Shit.
I don't remember it Randy. More than
once. I mean it might've dribbled. Yeah,
a couple of days.
We're supposed to have an El Nino
coming through this year and now they're
saying it's going to be a very
light version of it and we needed,
we needed a full El Nino. Well, we
need like a year of rain, right?
We need like a Seattle. Well, that
last El Nino was like that too.
Where you hear out here and like
net, was it 92, eight? No. Oh,
I'm sorry. No, no, no,
no. It was like 97 and uh,
it fucking rained every day
for like four months. Well,
me is their spots like death valley.
That's like right there.
It's on the same state.
So right there. Right.
What makes Death Valley Death Valley?
I don't understand it. I'm not,
I'm not a geo engineer.
I don't understand the weather patterns.
I mean, it's the hottest place in the
world, right? And it's right there. Yeah.
Why is it right there and why are
we not worried that right there,
it could be right here if that shit
creeps up north. Like what keeps it from,
is it the ocean? Like I don't understand
it. Is it, what is it that keeps, well,
there's a lot of spots.
Like how about Ontario?
Could that be like fucking death
valley someday? What about Breyer?
That's pretty God damn far from
the ocean that turn into some
horrible wasteland of that. All your
gigs. That's exactly right. Yeah.
Ontario Improv.
What about Pasadena so far?
Isn't it possible? Yeah. I mean, it
seems to me he said, you see Chinatown,
that movie Chinatown
with a Mickey Rourke now,
the original one with Jack
Nicklaus. Jack Nicholson. Yeah.
I mean it's just basically
about how that's exactly it.
La is a dust bowl and it's one,
one river coming down.
If you cut it off,
it all goes away.
Remember that movie we're watching
except for the fact to get his nose cut.
I remember that. Well, it's that.
It's the movie that most screenwriters
call the greatest script ever. Wow.
The houses in that movie. Your
House. Yeah. Wow. Let's skip.
Freaked me out when I watched it.
I was in Burbank.
The old Burbank Burbank
was a different animal.
You ever go to Jerry's Deli in woodland
hills and you see what the values to
look like back in the day? Oh, we have
all these like 1920 photos and shit. Yeah.
Big photos of oil, farmland
and ranches. Farms, ranches.
I W you know,
there's a real issue here and in Texas,
Texas is they're really worried about
it in Texas too with drought that there,
there's been no fucking rain and they
don't know what's going to happen.
And if it continues on this path,
we literally like there are lakes,
like not Lake Austin but
Lake Travis in Austin.
That is half the size that it used to be.
Yeah.
There's some photos of
California links that show,
like see if you could find that photos
of California lakes that show how bad the
drought is. Just, just Google that. Cause
I'm surprised it's not worse. You know,
we were just up in Yosemite and we went
rafting and it was plenty of fucking
water. Yeah, that's a good spot. You
know, if you go to the good spots, yeah,
it'd be all right. But that's why
I'm going to go to Canada. Um,
actually September 9th through
11th at the, um, Alberta
plugging my dates with the bull. Where
is it? Where are you going to Alberta.
Edmonton. Uh, what's the name of the club
up there? Your photos left and right.
Look at left and right, September
nine through 1130, all the water.
This is only a three years difference if
I remember correctly. Yeah. Holy Shit.
We used to look like,
look it looks like now and
climactic change is supposed
to happen over thousands
of years, not five. I
don't know about that.
I don't know if that's necessarily
true because there've been some radical
climactic changes that have happened
throughout history that have happened
almost instantaneous.
Yeah. There's some, uh,
there was some discovery channel show
that was talking about these various land
masses of these various um,
uh,
contours are weird things that you could
see on the ground and that scientists
had,
I'm pulling this out of my memory,
but scientists had realized that this
whole thing had to have occurred.
Like when the course of a small amount
of time, like over a couple of days yeah.
At these insane geological
features had been created.
Whether it's through soil samples,
I think it was like soil samples.
Like they tested the soil at the top and
the soil at the bottom was all the same
age.
Like the carbon dating.
I think like the Yucatan peninsula in
Mexico was a giant tsunami that settled on
top of the land and slowly just fucking
dribble down for thousands of years
until what was left is a is you know,
this, uh, what's now very lush
and, but it was underground for,
for all in one fucking
day went underwater.
Wow. That's fucking
nuts. But that happens.
It's just we have such a limited amount
of time that we're referring to or that
we're referencing when we're
looking at climate change.
We're only looking at a couple of hundred
years of accurate reporting. Yeah.
You get past then and it's just hearsay
and all those things that are in the
past that people point to like the stories
of climactic change and cataclysmic
disasters.
Those were all regional events that
happened in some place where someone wrote
about that.
Matt via,
yeah. Well there's that, but there's
also like the epic of Gilgamesh.
You want to go way back,
which is the same essential story in the
a lot of ways as the Noah's Ark Story.
Yeah. Where there's some
giant goddamn flood. You know,
there's some shit happens in your area,
a fucking up,
a big chunk of rock from space slams into
the ocean near your town and everybody
dies.
Everybody within a hundred miles is dead.
And then someone writes about,
that's the thing about the Bible,
most religions are based
on these categories. Like
the last book of the Bible,
the book of revelations was written at
the exact same time that mount Vesuvius
happened. And when they talk
about fire and brimstone,
that's what the guy was fucking
looking at as he wrote it.
So we've got written in as like,
this is how the world ends.
It's nuts. So the Bible, uh, apparently,
well, you know, they're all based on,
it's not how the world ends is how the
world ends there. If you go to Hawaii,
everybody's fine.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like everybody reports on
how fucked it is where they are,
but it's supposed to,
cause you're not supposed to stay.
Like we get totally married to the
idea of one geographic location.
But if anybody's paying any
attention to fucking history,
what we know about North America's,
that 10,000 years ago,
half of it was under a mile high
sheet of ice. There was no Wisconsin,
Wisconsin didn't exist.
You had to cut through the fucking mile
of ice to get to Minneapolis. I mean you,
you, there's no, you couldn't
get to it. It wasn't there.
So like this idea that that could be a
place where I got my family farms always
been here. We've been here since we
were kids and we're just not moving.
Climate change be gone.
No.
You're talking about like when we were
a nomadic civilization and just move to
where the weather.
Yeah.
Well yeah, that's what people did. I
mean, that's what people have always done.
And they did it because
we didn't have the,
we have this ridiculous ego now that
we can kind of live in any climate.
We'll fix it. I got an air conditioning.
We've go to a water coming in.
Don't worry, I'm not worried
about the hot, you know,
like we have this idea that you could be
in a totally inhospitable place and he
could fix it with technology.
And we're right for the most part.
But if that technology fails, I
had a guy on yesterday, Mike Baker,
who's the guy from the CIA,
he was the head of director
of operations for the CIA.
Now we are host a show
on the travel channel.
He was talking about how easy it is to
break the fucking power grid and that
that's what people should be worried
about. There's not that much power.
I mean there's not the, not, not that
much difficulty shutting down a grid.
And there's only like a couple of
grids that control the entire country.
And if one of those goes down, it takes
a long fucking time to come back up.
And before,
you know,
just in the last couple of years have
power grids go down and people are out for
days and it could be longer if
something bad happens to a power grid.
They give water supply power grid.
Power Grid is the big one because power
good keeps people from being able to
live in a place that's hot or
cold. Yeah. Like once it goes down,
like then you're off on your
own. Like do you really want, oh,
that's what I wanted to bring up.
There's something that I put up.
Josh McDermitt from the walking dead
pulled this up and he tweeted it to me and
it's on my Twitter.
I retweeted it.
The craziest fucking story about
a guy who lived in Maine. Okay.
And when he was 20 years old,
he disappeared and he went
into live into the woods.
Never spoke a word to anyone,
never, never interacted with people.
Said Hi once to a guy that
he found jogging that's all,
or hiking and lived off the land.
Stole from people.
They called them the hermit
of uh, whatever the fuck he
was. Did you find it? Yeah.
Let me just pull that shit up.
So it's like in a small town in Maine,
he lived in the woods behind it.
Exactly.
He lived in the woods and stole from
people for 20 years, 20 plus years.
It's a Co Raisie steal
food, batteries, food,
clothes, everything he had, he had
stolen and people from this town,
he had been a mystery because no
one knew if he was real or not.
So he had been a guy like the
Steal People's candy. Like the,
there was a guy who remembered
that when he was 10 years old,
someone stole all of his Halloween candy
and he couldn't believe it and people
would think you're crazy.
Like he would steal your propane tanks
and he would return like you would
replace them with an empty tank and
people would be like, what the fuck?
I had a full propane tank.
He would steal your grill.
He had like a grill out there and he
lived in a tent and he lived in a tent for
27 years and I mean fucking winters.
He's 47 years old and he
hasn't talked to anybody.
And this is the only interaction
that he's ever had with people.
He's never been sick a day in his
life. You think he'll do time? Oh yeah,
he'll do, but it's all
misdemeanor charges. Yeah,
but it's a thousand of them.
They got to prove them all.
He's got all the stuff.
It's all he has. I mean,
he's going to do time. Yeah.
It's how much you going to do the
guy a break. He's mentally ill. Kim,
lock them up and you want them out
there fucking robbing your house.
And I love stealing your candid foot.
It's like you,
there's a rumor that there's a guy
that lives in the woods. I mean,
how great is that to
be a kid in that town?
What's incredible that
it turned out to be real.
That's all these people thought this
for so long and everyone was like, no,
that's nuts.
Every town should have one guy who hides
and steal shit from you just to keep
you honest. Make sure you're
locking your gate it. Yeah,
but this is ridiculous because
this guy had tools he had in tools.
You would get into people's houses,
their alarms would go off and he knew
like how to get out of there just in time.
And so when the alarm would go off,
he would fucking bail.
I could see that as being not the
AA story in a, in a feature film,
but like the beast story.
Yeah. Yeah. You're like,
this is the guy that
has to come out of his,
he has to come out of his
shell to try to save humanity.
You find something that governments do
in the woods. No one's believe that guy.
He's crazy. Yeah. You know he stole my
kids' Halloween Candy. Right. Meanwhile,
he's out there and he's like,
I'm telling you,
they're pawning something really badly.
I haven't talked to people in 20 jamming
you. Yeah. Have you ever been to camp?
Ever been doing, he never
got, never got the local,
the kid hits a baseball over the fence
and stumbles into them and they strike a
relationship. Yeah. That
only he understands the man.
This guy got busted by a game warden.
There was a game warden
who knew he was doing this,
and so they set up this silent alarm.
The alarm went off,
and then this game warden showed up
with a flashlight and a gun and po po
blinded him with the flashlight and
pointed the gun on him and said,
get on the ground, and then they
caught him. This guy was like,
for all these years,
he was a myth.
I just can't imagine getting
through those winters in Maine.
Unbelievable. It doesn't get any colder
than that. It's about wet cold. Yeah.
It's about as miserable as you can
get on without being in Alaska,
I guess like northern Alaska
because it's on the ocean.
It's on the Northern Atlantic.
I bet he stole something like
maybe a dog house or he made some,
no, no, no, no. He lived in a tent. Wow.
He stole the tent, but he lived in a tent.
He stole everything he had,
except as glasses.
He had the same glasses that he wore
in high school. It's incredible.
I mean, the guy was like, he
had a high school yearbook.
He's wearing these glasses and then he's
like, you know what? I don't like people.
Fuck this. He never saw the
internet. He's never gotten an email.
He's never watched a television show.
He hasn't seen anything in 27 years.
What do you do? Read books. I read books.
How he stole books and read them. Yeah.
I love books. Like Tom Clancy books. Stole
People's books. Had a stack of books.
Yeah, no, he broke his glasses.
It's hard to steal glasses.
I'd be like that twilight zone episode.
Yeah, that's what Burgess Meredith. Yeah.
Crazy story though,
man.
Because you only hear about stuff
like that and you're just like,
that's bullshit. There's no guys live in
27 fucking years in the woods in Maine.
But yes, there was. Yes, there
was and we got to find out why.
There's a reason why he left and
went in the woods. Mental illness,
I would imagine. Did you read into
the wild? Yes. It's kind of like that.
There was like a something that drove and
it wasn't like an event that made that
guy, he wasn't traumatized, you know?
I think his parents had
divorced and he took it hard,
but basically he just had a spirit
that needed to be away from man. He,
he couldn't handle man, but he
didn't like it when he was out there.
That's the thing, um, that
they, they, they talked about
a little bit in the movie,
you know,
it was like all this beauty doesn't
mean anything if there's no one share it
with, I think there was a quote, but
what, what I didn't like about the movies,
the movie altered book in the book,
the reality of how the guy died,
the reality of how he died is he got
injured and they starved to death. Yeah.
And in the book there was one
version of it and then the movie,
they tried to make it that he ate some
poisonous plant that he fucked up and ate
the wrong plant.
Though I remember in the book they
did mention that as a possibility.
They didn't say,
ultimately that's what it was.
I think they were pretty sure
that he starved to death.
Yeah. Yeah. There was no,
it's not easy to get food,
man. It's not easy. It's,
it's the idea of living
off the land is ridiculous.
So I think he had planned on getting out
before winter set in and he missed the
window.
And so he got stuck out there.
Well he was only a few miles from
people too. Oh no shit. Yeah.
I mean look that area, like you're in
Alaska. Alaska is incredibly remote,
but I don't believe he was more
than like five or 10 miles away from
civilization. I think the PR,
you know, poor fucking guy.
There's people that could have
helped them that we're right there.
I wonder if this is a tourist spot
where the bus was that he was living in.
There's nothing like it had a van or
a bus or something like a school bus.
Then he find it out there or something
and move into it or something was broken
down bus. But that was
sad, man, because look,
you can do it like survivor man's done it,
but you gotta be fucking prepared if you,
if you want to live in the
woods by yourself, man,
you better have plenty of food.
You had better have plenty of ammo.
If you're going to hunt, you better
have some way of stockpiling plants.
If you're not going to hunt,
you got to figure out how you're going
to and you've got to have a serious
understanding of nature. You know what
stuff you can eat, what you can't,
how to build a fire, how to
like, how to predict the weather.
To some degree it's probably really hard
to do but you shouldn't be at least be
able to survive.
Like there's a bunch of those shows
that are about people living in Alaska.
There's a bunch of those shows now,
but one of the crazy ones is life
below zero and a light bulb zero.
There's a couple of these guys that have
cabins and they live out and all they
do all day is go out and get food,
whether it's fishing or hunting.
They shoot Caribou and they hang them.
And this one guy,
his name is Glenn and he has like this
little shack that he's prepared up there
in, in Alaska and he lives in this little
shack and it's by a lake and he has a
drill holes in the leg to pull his water
out or take snow and he melted down.
That's the only way he gets from the no
electricity just to fire, just to fire.
And he makes all of his fire.
Um,
he doesn't use matches because he
feels like you could lose your matches.
So he has this thing like an old school
Indian thing, he bites down on it,
he holds it in a stick and the stick
is attached to these two ropes, like a,
like a, um, or a rope rather than a bow.
Like almost like one of those
things you would play fiddle with.
And he goes like this with eight bytes
it down. So he holds it in place,
just goes [inaudible] and then he
goes back and forth in the friction,
creates sparks and then he
uses that to start up Tinder.
That's the only way he makes fire and
this guy's out there just shooting things
and eating them.
But the crazy thing is like he's happy,
like he enjoys it.
He lives as a hermit for like four or
five months out of the year and he does
that. And then occasionally
he has a family apparently
like his divorced from his
wife,
but he has kids so he goes into town
and he does it during the winter months.
Yeah, he does it through the
winter. Yeah. It's crazy.
I don't know how much
of it is for the show.
That's a real issue when you
watch these goddamn shows. Yeah.
You don't know how much of this
they're doing. Like they said, hey,
would you be willing to live out
there through the winter? Like yeah,
maybe you only does it
during the summer normally,
but he did it in the winter on TV.
But what's weird is like when I,
when we stayed in Yosemite,
we had to put all our food in these bare
safes that were like reinforced steel
because any food at all,
they're going to come find it.
But what do you do when you've got an
elk hanging outside of your cabinet?
I was constantly fighting off grizzlies.
This guys constantly, he shoots,
grizzlies is constantly fighting them off.
They find out about
his stash and you know,
he has to like when he shoots an animal
needs to be very careful approaching it
because of a bear gets to the end before
he does like a lot of times you shoot
an animal in the animal
will run off to die. Like,
cause they have a lung or they
have their full of air, you know,
their lungs are a bullet will go
through one long, the animal runs,
it might take 10 15 minutes for it
to die if you don't hit it perfectly.
So he has to track the animal, but by
the time he gets it in the animals down,
he has to decide if he shoots the animal,
like say like if it gets dark at seven
and he shoots the animal at six and he's
tracking it. If he goes
too far, he's gotta go,
I gotta get home before it gets dark
because he doesn't have flashlights. Yeah,
he's not using any of that shit. Okay.
I got to leave this animal there.
So then he has to go out first light.
So he goes out in the morning to find
the animal and sometimes something's
founded already like nocturnal animals.
So he might get to his carcass of all
of his meat. This is what he needs.
He shot this animal,
but there's a wolf on it or this bears
on it or something along those lines.
Serious Shit.
What that,
that excitement about being
out there like that for,
this guy's like this giant charge.
That's what he loves to do.
He doesn't want to deal with taxes.
He doesn't want to deal with jobs.
He doesn't want to deal with bosses.
He's just got this little shack that he
built himself and he could sell skins.
So like he can, um, he can
get like, you can trap,
you can trap animals
like links and you know,
all these different animals and sell
their skins and make money. So he,
that's where he gets his money from.
Then from that money he'll buy like
bullets and guns and things along those
lines. And everything else.
He's just living off the land.
So he lives off the land like for
months and months at a time with no one,
no contact,
doesn't speak to another
human being for four months.
Well he's doing it now because
he's talking to cameraman
obviously and producers
I'm sure.
And we ended up,
I'm sure there's people there that are
kind of directing weird for him because
he clearly he doesn't
want to be around people.
And when you've got a camera
crew around you around the clock,
you got no space at all.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I mean maybe it's only during the day
and then they have specific times with a
film,
like they need to get some
nighttime content or need
to get some content of him.
Like they've got a different ones.
There's a couple of different guys
and one guy's a, um, he's a, uh,
a hunting guide.
His name is Eric and he's a hunting guide.
So he takes people hunting and
then when he's not doing that,
then he has his own spot. But he has
a generator and he has an actual,
and he's a bit, he has like,
he drives around in four by
fours, those little work,
you know those little things,
those Polaris things. Yes.
That's how he and snowmobiles actually
snowmobiles is really the way he does it.
And that's how he gets around.
He uses a snowmobile to travel through
the woods and check his trap lines and
stuff. So he's like step up from this
guy like a little, he has a generator,
has power, little bit more
technological, but you know,
you go all the way back to that guy and
he's not even using matches. You know,
these fucking guys there, they're
loving it. That's what's crazy.
It's like the challenge and the thrill
of life changes because there are tuned
in and that's what they always talk about.
Like when you're out here,
it's so exciting because you're tuned
into nature. You know, like he was,
he was their hunting,
all these different animals and some of
them they're hunting for furs and some
of which I don't like. You know, when I,
when I see people hunting shit for furs,
I'm always like, man, that's Kinda fucked
up. But when I watch these guys do it,
I don't,
it doesn't bother me.
It doesn't bother me that they're shooting
these animals only for their first
cause. Like this guy doesn't have
any other way to get money. Yeah.
I mean this is what he's chosen
to do and there's a reason why.
I mean they would try to keep the
populations of a lot of these animals and
check and so they need
people like this to do that.
But it's just such a weird way of life
to watch and I always watch it go.
Could I do that?
That's why these shows are so popular.
He's Alaska shows are huge and they
keep making a million. But you know,
I could say on the, on the slightest
scale of this, when I go camping,
I feel so good.
I come back refreshed.
I feel like I'm connecting with my family.
Like I never do news, no cell phones,
we're talking, we're doing projects
like lighting a fire, cooking some food,
putting the tents up. Going
for a hike and you think, yeah,
I always bring a book or some games, I
never get to that shit. Your Day is full.
Yeah, it's a, it's a relaxing but
invigorating way to spend your time.
It's weird. Yeah. But I
think people need trees.
I think like being around that stuff,
like walking on dirt and being around
trees, we don't need it obviously,
but I think there's a certain energy
that you get from that environment that's
refreshing. It feels good. Yeah.
To me in every religion talks about, it's
all the answers are in nature. You know,
you read Whitman and Thoreau,
it's all about go to Walden pond,
just get off the grid and that's the
only way you can live. And it's like,
even if it means taking a hike every
other day, just get out in nature.
All the answers are there.
You, you ponder the cycles,
you see a flower dying
and you think about, oh,
there's some horse shit
that's gonna make this grow.
And you see a bird feeding something.
Like you just see how life
really works on a base level.
And I think he kind of gets you in sync.
Yeah. I think what we're doing by
creating cities is awesome. I mean,
we're stockpiling food.
It makes it easy to get around your car.
It's nice to be able to visit your
friends. You just drive across town. Hey,
what's up everybody? And everybody
fucking let's green. Light means go.
Red Light means stop. No, it's
all good. Got a nice system,
but I think we're missing
out on a lot of Shit, man.
I think we're missing out on a lot of the
feeling that you get from just being a
person. I think that's one of the
reasons why we're so detached from our,
the the actions that we are doing as
far as like polluting as far as like
dumping plastic into the ocean,
we're so detached from it
because in cities we're only
seeing this human created
stuff. But when you see like a beer, can
you see a beer can in a parking lot? Say,
if you're walking through a parking lot,
see a smashed Budweiser can,
it doesn't really freak you out. But when
you see a Budweiser can in the woods,
it's a real bummer man. Yeah,
it's a real bummer. You know,
I've seen people throw cigarettes out
like on a parking lot and it's gross,
but it seems normal.
But I see,
I saw a dude wants throw a cigarette out
in the woods and I go pick that up, man.
The fuck are you doing?
We're out here in the woods.
It's beautiful out here and you just let
your cigarette threw it on the ground.
Stepped on it. Fuck you.
That's what the ocean is.
It's forever been a dumping
ground. I mean, just, just,
I mean, so to hear about the,
uh, the, the, uh, trash continent
that disappeared, disappeared,
disappeared.
What do you mean disappeared?
Somebody just told me yesterday that the
thing that's been floating out in the
ocean that's the size of
Australia is no longer there.
I don't think it's that big. It's pretty
big. I think it's like Texas size,
but it's uh, the Pacific Garbage Patch
is what the Christ appeared. Really? Yup.
Wow. I didn't hear that. And you
know, when you think about like, uh,
it's just too easy to dump
shit into the, uh, 99% missing.
Oh my God.
99% missing.
It's reached the food
chain. Ugh. God, yeah.
Ocean patches mysteriously disappearing.
What the fuck?
Those guy who had on who's a c Stutter,
he's a good,
this idea of I'll run out of time,
but he,
they were talking about this a 19 year
old kid and figured out a way to pull
plastic out of the ocean,
use some sort of large machine and he's
done on a small scale base skateboards
out of it. Uh, no, we talked about that.
I think the last time you were here,
some guy down in Mexico, right? Right. No,
this was a guy who figured out how to
clean up the Pacific garbage patch and
reuse that plastic. Oh yeah. Yeah.
That was small scale. They've uh,
they've shown it like, um, what's that
called? Proof of concept on a small scale.
So it's now it's a matter of
implementing it on a large scale.
But if it's all fucking sinking
into the ocean, that's not good.
It's like that Gulf oil spell like
where to go. Not Good. He's gone.
But the reality is of that
the ocean is so fucking big.
If you do cap it, eventually everything
will recover. It's obviously not good.
But the reality is oil leaks from the
ground far for the ocean floor also.
I mean it does it all the time.
Like throughout the California coast you
could find natural oil that has leaked
out of the bottom of the ocean,
like the ocean floor.
The same way we can go in
and get it with a pipe,
it can actually come
through in some spots. Yeah.
So the ocean is not worried about that
amount of, it's fucked up and grows.
And for the people that live in
that area, disgusting, awful, evil,
all the above. But the whole ocean, it's
like Kimberly and Doris was, is when the,
uh, when the Soviet Union went
down, they got a, all these,
all these classified documents came out
about the nuclear program for like 40
years.
They were taking raw nuclear waste and
just dropping it in the Sea of Japan.
Just take it out, throw it overboard.
Motherfuck and we're eating Sushi.
Well that's how the Somali
pirate started, you know? Yeah.
The Somali pirates before they
call themselves Somali pirates,
they call themselves the
volunteer coast guard of Somalia.
And the reason why they
started doing this,
they start going out and
capturing European boats
that were dumping toxic waste
off the coast, killing off all their
fish. I'll hold them for ransom.
And then they realize,
you know,
we get a lot more than this then we do
do in fishing. Yeah. So fuck fishing.
Let's just become kidnappers.
So they became kidnappers and
started making millions of dollars.
Give a man a fish. He'll eat for a day,
but take a bunch of people hostage.
That's a fucking months worth of money.
Hey,
dad
podcast is brought to you by draft kings.
Was it?
Is that what you call it?
What's the URL? Draft kings.com.
No, no, no. This is it. You are all
like you. You add something in there.
Code Codeword Rogan. Okay. Is that it?
Yeah. I never get these things correct.
Okay.
Draft kings.com entering the Codeword
Rogan for free entry now@draftkings.com.
Get on that fantasy football train
and make yourself some money.
I can't believe you can really make money,
but uh,
you can you get your piece of 5 million
bucks during kickoff week@draftkings.com
use the code word Rogan and you can
try it for free. Enter for free.
Give it a shot. You fucks. And
Greg Fitzsimmons was your website.
Greg fitzsimmons.com fits dog.com the,
uh,
my new one hour special from comedy
central is now on Hulu for free on stage.
Check that out. And then if you
want to see my bullshit live,
I'll be in Edmonton on
September nine 11 through 13.
And then Atlanta October 13 to 15.
Go to Greg's website more at the time.
We love the fuck out of you.
People see you next week.
Big Kiss
did
it.
Oh yeah. Is he dead? Oh yeah,
but then what's crazy? I don't
even bring it up, but I thought
they were like, oh yeah,
it's completely legal hit.
Actually the shooting age eight Oh my God.
Not only that,
but their marketing to kids like
crazy. Yeah. That's like the,
they have like whole magazine
for kids. They've been gun. Yeah.
And it's all put out by the NRA.
Beautiful. Uzi. I been fucking,
I've shot one gun once and it
was like a little, what is it?
A 22 is that those little tiny little baby
ones? That's all I shot. The girl ones.